i'm gonna have to go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right all right what's going on
what's going on
my manfrotto in the realm talking that
talk
yeah you know we're gonna talk about
that uh that fandom that's uh solves
joe bailey what's going on it's a little
cat daddy in there early i see you
what's going on everybody got attic in
the realms alex say what's up to the
people man
[Music]
he's in the bushes as usual co-host
in the bushes no i'm here you can't hear
me well i can hear the people would like
to hear you do a little sound check
brother
you know so let me know if y'all can
hear addict
what is in the bush itself
hustling motivate what's going on bro
what's going on i see you
booty time what's going on here sorry
about the ufc bulldog time and i was
trying
i was just so busy bro so just let me
know how the levels are sounding
you know what i'm saying make sure y'all
heard at it thank you thank you hustle i
appreciate that
appreciate that so we file and then
we're going to get neo
game spark in the realm soon get them up
in there ken you know won't pull up soon
for that copyright strike
you know what i'm saying oh they're
looking out boy yeah we're going to do
what we talked about though for sure
and um yeah man that's pretty much it so
i'm gonna go back on mute king will be
in here with his beats
and i'm not trying to get hit with no
copyright strike
so i will see y'all in a minute
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
might check mic check and
we are at testing
are testing welcome to the iron lords
podcast
and the lords of gaming.net episode
number 172
and it's another glorious sunday we're
back in front of the round table
on the lord's day i'm very excited about
our special guest and we've got four
guys success
dc fandom reveals and black myth
woo kong to discuss so we gonna get
right into it
i want to introduce a lord who has not
only been a consistent star as a content
creator
but at its very core defines what it
means to be a true lover of multiplied
video games
and anime whether it be insightful q a's
or intellectual rare debates
all done with refreshing objectivity
introducing the creating host of the neo
gamespark youtube channel
the cumonto of anime and manga
and the tall lord with glasses who
always
makes us be real about life for a hot
second
live from the mecca of new york
and making his debut into the realm of
the lords
my man lord neo game spark how you doing
sir
i'm doing pretty good man thank you
thank you that intro is this
damn this man did his homework come on
through anime dave
that's not that's not a name i've heard
what you do good to finally have you in
the realm first of all how you doing man
what you
going on what you've been playing what's
been going on man i'm doing good man i'm
doing great man it's an honor to be on
this show so
you know it's amazing uh right now what
i'm playing i'm going through you know
because we are
objective multi-platform gamer i'm
playing a couple things you know ori and
will the wisps i'm playing that on my
one x uh going through the last of us
part two
finishing that up to get like my final
verdict and
fall guys man those are the three things
i've been focusing on as a lady fall
guys is amazing i played that game i
played that with jagmu till like four in
the morning yeah i was blazing last
night
[Laughter]
you know it was it was bull because that
tail game so busted because it's like
it's like sometimes i feel like i can
grab that tail like right
up and then sometimes i have to like be
right on them and i miss it and i just
don't understand
it was just it was me jack and one other
person and and jack won
and of course he had to put that on
twitter
they said we got the kung fu lip sync i
don't know what's going on cool
so sorry oh oh really hopefully
they don't bleed like wow like last week
but anyway
and you already know we got the full
hospital gaming those original lords of
the realm here at the round table
my co-host nicole most my brother from
another mother the difficult game
conqueror
lord of reviews and the how of the young
wolf
my man lord addict how are we doing sir
doing pretty good uh
still a little tired you know i woke up
at like 12
15 something like that and i looked at
the clock and i was like do i really
need to do this podcast today
i was like man i was like i'm tired
o'clock and i just woke up so tired but
i just playing fall guys
all those hours but i went to bed way
later and just been completely fine i
don't know
and just finally caught up to you yeah
it's just colgate getting older
[Laughter]
and of course we have our most technical
gaming launch
who lives with the single-player selfish
experience and also the sasha
davis mr offline profile illuminati and
lord patron of the iron bank
my man lord sovereign how we doing sir
what's going on man i'm doing good
i mean i feel awake i don't know why you
guys said i was not looking away but i
feel i don't know
i have played let's see what i played
this week i i played microsoft's uh
flight simulator wow i did i got it to
download after like three days of like
what's up with them playing that too
yeah you caught me oh yeah yeah i
definitely called you catching me
playing into the series
i mean it is it is gorgeous it is
absolutely gorgeous like i don't know
of any other thing that i've seen that
is that pretty um
what excites me most is how they're
going to use that tech in later games
like i've
i've heard a lot of people talk about
forza horizon being able to use
something like that so but i mean
flight simulator is just that like the
good thing about it is that you can
really
you can really cater the experience to
how you want it so if you want to play
it sort of arcade you can do that and if
you
know nothing about airplanes you can
still enjoy it that way so
it's cool i'm going to get back into it
i played battle toads
um i liked it i liked it it's it's
very polarizing yeah people people are
putting it in the same breath as streets
of rage 4 and that's
they need to relax let's not do that
relax yeah
they need the rocks well i mean it
destroys streets rage 4
oh
right now
i'm just saying it's just a matter of
opinion you know
you want real polish hot stuff i'm just
saying wow
continue
yes i'm late but let's make sure we get
into cogs crazy eating habits today
oh no no no we're not gonna do that bro
because you what he's gonna laugh he's
talking about the like wait two is my
second
i got him i got one he's talking about
the last word
and he boxes don't put no condiments on
his food so i told him he's crazy
so that is what kind of condiments
though like let's talk about condiments
no condiments they are you know jailed
there's very few things i actually eat
caught them and so oh yeah another one
of them got damn no
you're a white girl anyways
anyway
my segment always gets hijacked it does
not matter
[Laughter]
we got time constraints i can't do that
we got time to be always on a trick time
schedule
yeah let's go
and of course we have the incredible
hulk of this aka
the access gamer the lord of combat
sports
king of the statues who demands nothing
less than that premium experience
it is the leader of the fraud alert
movement
beloved lord gig how are we doing sir
i'm doing fantastic
shout out to the great white shark
alexander povetkin
boy just when you thought it was safe to
go back in the waters again
your boy is still out there 40 years old
and
still handing out dynamite chunks of
punches
beautiful beautiful i love that uppercut
i love the way you said it
i love your commentary with the uppercut
yeah that was
your song wasn't it vintage
king is vince's king went back in the
day when we're all in the same room
laughing our behinds off at because king
would do his own play-by-play
and whenever it went down the way he
said oh you're gonna hear it
don't let it be your man that he predict
is going under the rope and it go down
and he gotta give you the funny
play-by-play
you gotta laugh you gotta laugh so being
that we doing the social distancing
right my man
is on the camera right so i'm talking to
him on the camera right
and we talking back and forth and
he like yeah white got him son and i
said
oh you really think so hey the voice the
other day
i said this is the time where convection
turns it up on him
yo when he knocked him out i said yo
just make sure you cash out me that 200.
without the box punches like that's what
he is he's glottal without the box
punches
so much potential oh man okay
well um everything he's about to say is
on game yeah let me just put the game
pass on doji
right now right now you're right adam
i'm just getting ready though right
there we go here's the game pass segment
first of all first of all shout out to
phil dominus maximum spencer's soon to
be a realist
i actually soar
this man dropped flight simulator
and battle toad y'all thought you was
gonna get it and then i didn't get
none of that smoke remember all the
hahahihi
kiki cuckoo
he was like oh this is a saturday
morning cartoon i mean how can you get
to smoke like you you don't really
like attack people like that so people
scared
but you know what it is all that battle
toes talk about trash
like nah like that is objectively like
if you just think it's you just hating
hate like
people don't like
i can tell you the difference from when
we played the game at e3 when we played
the game at e3 and i was talking to the
developers
it didn't have any voice overs oh all
right so
it was just literally just text on the
screen the music stayed rocking
the frame rate and everything was solid
everything you saw there was solid
they added an extra sheen to it to the x
yeah with the parallax scrolling um
and that's what i saw from it but then
when i saw the cartoon
addition to it right it took it up
another notch they went above and beyond
this is what i asked for microsoft if
this is
your uh your one of your franchise one
of your pillars whatever
whatever a game that's coming out of
your house right right
they double checked it they looked at it
they heard all the memes they saw the
stuff and this gives me hope for all the
stuff coming later
but they actually put out a
very good quality title that had a ton
of question marks around it
now it might not be your cup of tea but
you cannot
say that the game isn't one of the best
side scroll and be the most modern that
we've gotten lately i heard it's solid
i have one question for you i haven't
played battle toads yeah
so sell me on it man sell me on
the sole reason to play this game is
because it's in game passes
any level of quality game is good
because it's a game pass
no i say this yo i play neon abyss
recklessly all damn day long
i would have never played that game if
it wasn't in game pass
i purchased the game because the game
was
lit all right i purchased the messenger
because the game was lit
if i never tried any of these 16-bit
games that was never going to get my
money nothing
if it wasn't in game pass and at the
same time new super lucky tail came out
i'll say this it's a lot better than i
expected it okay i was expecting it
you know like with the the memes running
around
the xbox game template 69 on metacritic
i was expecting it to be terrible but i
played it and i actually am really
knowing a lot of it i really am i think
it's cool
um the lack of online co-op is
definitely a deal breaker for me
long term yes and i think that's part of
the reason why a lot of people like this
game
unless they do some type of uh uh an
update where they add it in
it's literally gonna live and die and
that's gonna be end of it that's all she
wrote
see now that's what i'm telling the only
thing i'm i'm upset with them is that
and this has happened again when they
had a kind of solid
side scroller you know co-op joint like
a cuphead
how is the online not in this how like
that to me is inexcusable for that type
of game you could really extend the life
of the game imagine if co-op
if cuphead's co-op online was there if
battle told three player online club now
you're getting that engagement and
people playing together
and it's just like it's kind of like
damn this is a microsoft studio like
to be honest with you yeah yeah at the
moment
i'm sorry yeah he's right super chat sup
iop
when i heard about the thing going on
with um
it not having a a
a multiplayer thing and going on launch
it like
right there already nope not play you
know yeah
you know for a lot of people that's a
complete deal breaker and i can
understand why streets of rage
will rank higher than that and also
streets rage also has
uh ties to our uh yeah whole you know so
i was trying to
go to battle towards right and they
battle tools they i mean
let me be clear it
absolutely 100 improves upon that old
formula like that
it 100 improves upon i just
i feel like something is iconic as
battletoads
needs and the fact that we didn't have
that years ago that you can have that
now
yeah they're like people talking like
iconic hey yo
did you play them old games
so are we going to say that it's not
like on it no it's not to me
it's like because of how bad it was and
difficult
that was all it was if you were able to
beat that game back in the day you got a
badge that's like it was our dark souls
it was literally are you inferring that
it's the dark souls before dark souls
did you play yo bro
is that trucker hat addict oh my god
i didn't have the hat we have to have we
just we're the overall
turn look man look man
i'm going to next week you're going to
get the head the hat now overalls attic
but
it's true do i get the wife no hold up
hold up the hat with the overalls with
attic
with the seat that's what you're going
to do
you're going no stretching no you're
going to kill billy jill
but you guys are doing too much
neo shaking his head like
[Music]
you know and destiny like always no and
of course we have the gaming ninja
himself the shinobi
lord cognito spreading that real
intimate iop not telling what you want
to hear but what you need
to hear shout out to the last word we
had the iconic
destiny artist the gamma trap absolutely
hilarious
shout out to the old men too shout out
we had it bust out into like a food
episode i don't know how it did it was
kind of hilarious
and we started talking about ease
choices on food and condiments cause you
rude yeah i'm rude you're rude
i'm very rude you know me i'm very
opinionated and passionate so oh yeah we
had to talk about that so shout out to
them i've been doing my solstice grind
i'm on the last steps got that rocking
also like all soft i tried uh flight
simulator
that thing was 90 gigs and my pc was
like yo what's going on in here
yo it was it was lit so was the first
place you went to
um actually i was just doing some basic
job i just put in like jfk
you know saying different airports and
simulating flights and stuff like that
but
the real time streaming with the almost
like that
i'm not not google but like bing maps or
whatever it is they're using yeah
it's is truly phenomenal tech so i get
it
you know shout out to i gotta i gotta
plug my dudes right now shout out the
lords of gaming dot net cause uh shout
out
device got a tremendous review up on
lawrencegaming.net right now please
check that out
that's what put it over for me for at
least try it you know and then i started
to see
the public response and i'm like you
know okay this this is something so they
need to get that out
for the uh time okay here
oh
i actually haven't haven't played more
of it
i fell off but i guess what i'm excited
about which one guess what i'm excited
about
well over here i want to play that
foreplay
20 minutes of that just drop that yeah
everybody say that he said that when i
was gonna do that and i'm not about to
finish going to sleep
i'm talking now i never said that last i
respect i
respect you i think i'ma have to bend
the knee to you i swear
your best friend christopher hart said
in the chat so 72 is not i don't know
um yeah man so that's pretty much it for
me but uh look we got to get moving
so now that we got to what the lords
have been playing all that good stuff i
want to start with lord
neo game spark his video game system
history
his journey as a content creator and of
course what led him to creating his
outstanding youtube channel so
lord neo let's start from the very
beginning man like what were some of the
first video game systems you had and
what got you into gaming
yeah of course so uh it started out as a
most of my gaming experiences did in the
90s my dad just came home with the
console and he's just like
here oh salute beautiful yeah
straight up he was just like he came
home one day with a super nintendo and
it had monopoly
and uh i forget which mario was on it
but we had both of those and so
literally it was just three-year-old me
trying to figure out how to play
monopoly
yeah yeah three years old three years
old
was trying to play monopoly and uh that
didn't go nowhere but i like the idea
of gaming though so uh we ended up
getting an n64 a few years later and i
think like the first my like first
big video game experience was playing uh
zelda ocarina of time
and then from there i was just hooked i
mean i didn't beat the game until like
three years later
like you know when you're younger and
you play a game and you think it's like
40 50 hours long and then you revisit as
an
adult it's like four hours where did
that come from
um so that's that's how it started out i
started a game with the super nintendo
into the n64 and then i started
branching out into other genres uh the
ps2 was where i first started like
it really start to click like yo this
this this is for me you know cause i
started playing
a lot of jrpgs you know final fantasy 10
kingdom hearts and then ironically i
went back to experience the ones that i
didn't on the super nintendo gotcha um
but like i always had that like hobby i
knew from that point like yo this this
is gonna be with me until the day i die
like i'm not giving up gaming
uh the youtube content creation that
started
uh i had the idea of doing it a year
after youtube open because you know when
you first
figure out youtube you're like yo what
is this site you know you had all the
other websites they had video players
but it was a website dedicated to doing
content
correct and i thought it was interesting
you know i was a bored kid in uh middle
school going into high school so
i just started uploading random videos
you know like whenever there was
trailers for
uh games i was looking forward to on
like ign or or uh game spot whatever
game trailers oh man y'all remember
trailers
oh yeah oh yeah yeah so i would upload
those things
and i guess um from uploading those
videos the ones that really got a lot of
traction where the ones uh relate to
anime so like dragon ball
and naruto and so people really enjoyed
those we got to talk it in the comment
sections and for me it was
it was like yo these are people that i
really vibe with because i had i have
folks in the real who i was cool with at
the time yeah but you know how
you uh you have people who you cool with
outside and then you have your boys
yeah you just connect you talk about
like whatever like like y'all do at the
beginning of the podcast just talk about
whatever
your crazy food habits all that you know
um so i i started meeting those people
and then one day
um since i was really big into playing
import games uh there was a naruto game
that came out in japan
uh i imported it i had the free loader
and then nintendo
they uh they they patched it out and i
was like so pissed off
and then someone sent me a link like yo
here's how you can play the games hack
your wii and i uploaded a tutorial video
let's get it enterprise nintendo didn't
show up on your front porch oh man
they tried to get me for a few things
but wow
that was my first on-camera video this
was uh circa summer 2008
wow and from there like that was the
first time i ever recorded a video
edited a video uploaded it
and it was just go let me stop it for a
second because
you started so young in my opinion like
what you didn't have i guess my question
for you because again i'm older so i
gotta ask
these younger generation questions like
like you didn't have any fear to just
for putting yourself out there like that
like you were just like what just said
you know what i'm gonna do it and i
don't care what people think or
whatever like what gave you that
confidence
uh well i did have a fear uh it's called
having
an ethiopian mother
if she ever did find out i was doing oh
you was doing this
i was doing it very low key until one
day
like when i start when you start doing
camera videos and recording you know
people start hearing like yo you talking
to yourself
it really it really be like that like
that's a good point that's a good point
so like they never walked in while you
was doing it or like how did the
discovery happen
so the discovery happened uh one day my
mom walked in i was talking to a camera
she's like what are you doing i was like
i don't know what to tell her like what
was it live
no i don't know it wasn't live so this
was like 2008. so i was actually just
recording
uh the video for it um and then i was
just like
i'm uploading videos online and you know
my mom she she's watched tons of uh
dateline to catch a predator and she's
like oh
no no no no no she's like they're not
getting my little boy they're not
getting my little
that's not my believe me not my baby
why are you uploading videos to internet
no you can't do that
i got a ton of funny stories with me and
my mom back and forth in the formative
years
i'll tell you about that later but
confidence wise um
i guess it was because there was really
no one around doing this sort of thing
that's why i didn't have any fear of
uploading
um but if i had to pick like an
inspiration you know i grew up watching
you know g4 and all those things i like
the idea
of you know them just talking about
games you know i'm saying like oh this
is it this is what we're looking forward
to like that stuff was great so
i wanted to do the same thing and i just
i just started uploading and i thought
nothing of it and then
people started watching the videos and
you know the early days of youtube i
mean for a lot of the younger cats out
there
they might not understand why it's so
nostalgic for us older
buddies like when it's something new you
know uncharted water
territory it was beautiful it was so
beautiful that's why
apologies the other apologies neil oh we
have early dan with the father super
chat got my baby girl gaming before she
could walk
i need a partner in these streets
that was crazy and then like you went
through you weren't originally
neil gainsbot you went through a name
change you know any history of the
backstory with that
change like i had a transition or
something
from seeing the super saiyan
behind the original name of course yeah
so
uh again i was um when i created my
first account i was like 14 years old
and you know i was really big into
naruto so
i was thinking of some type of screen
name that would click oh i didn't want
to do the usual
xx naruto xy xbag fight
sounds like a like a porn site or
something
but the name change how it happened was
i had already been through two accounts
because you know youtube back in the day
oh they can
write your channel down yeah no
questions asked so i wanted to have like
another
channel as a backup but i wanted to make
it um i wanted to like centralize it
around gaming
so originally i wanted to be called like
game spark so it sounds like a game show
you know i'm saying that's what i wanted
to do
that name was taken so i'm just sitting
here thinking yo what am i going to make
and blah blah and
either it was the youtube creation
system that came up with the name like
an autofill
or i just got done watching the matrix i
haven't figured out
oh the video okay okay i get it i see
the vibes i see the vibes
right so i just came up i'm like neo
gamespark and i made that channel and i
thought nothing of it for an entire year
because i'm like
i'm good i had success on the second
channel so that got struck down
right back back up channel it is and
literally
from 2009 until now that's that's what
it's been oh that's what's up man salute
trevette is trevetta's day trevette is
history always fun to see to hear those
stories
and then obviously i gotta instigate as
i said pre-show i mean one thing that
you are known for besides video games
obviously is the the anime you know what
i'm saying you do things like
that i thought which was really cool the
subs versus dubs you know what i'm
saying
i thought that's really cool you also do
a lot of q and a live vlogging i don't
even know why that's an argument
i don't know why people care what you
listen to here we go this is what i was
looking for
this isn't a shot at him because i don't
know how he feels about that but i don't
i literally
cannot grasp why people care what you
watch anime in
subs i didn't realize until i watched
leo's video i didn't realize how
passionate it is oh no it's it's it's
serious it's crazy
really because i've i've seen people
argue about it for hours
we just did that on the statue show on
friday really
because they was putting up naruto
statues and
i was saying that's the um my my
yeah greatest animates uh series ever
right
and one dude just was like how the hell
could you say that
there's one piece there's berserk and i
said okay statistics say
in the united states that that is the
number one
next to dragon ball z 102 flip flop any
given week
uh animate that's in america that don't
make it the best i said i'm just going
to statistics and beating your little
fake facts
i've seen because i i do tick talk and
i've seen
i follow a lot of content no
what are you doing what are you doing
you're dancing on tick-tock
time so i remember one time you know
uh they'll do like reactions to people
that's never watched something
and you know how many times i've like
scrolled through the comments and people
were like but you're watching it dubbed
so i just completely scrolled by
it is crazy culture video i don't have
much experience i'm
pretty much about anime fraud but i just
thought it was interesting you know
so like tell us about that just you know
expanding your channel with the anime
side and these type of
debates and q and a stuff that you do
yeah so that uh the subs versus dubs
video you're talking about i think i
made that like
eight years ago now that i think about
so it was a long time ago
uh so i don't really remember what i
said in it but
how that how that happened was um
since i like talking about naruto since
around me there's a few people who like
the anime but if
if i'm just gonna be real about life for
a second they were too into that
i'm talking like yo i like naruto i have
like the the headbands and stuff i put
in my room but these people they was
bringing that to school you know about
the kids running with their arms back
so literally like i would you know like
i would bring my um um i'm not sure
about y'all friend with uh the shonen
jump magazine you know
yeah japanese manga they used to come
out every month here
and i had a tradition you know every
tuesday i'd go pick it up from the
grocery store stop and shop and i come
and i bring some people and i remember
one day what yeah shout out to stop shop
[Laughter]
uh one day i brought that to school and
when i say like
i guess because i had closed it on the
lunch table to talk to a friend i saw
someone just pass by
and like i said he came over my shoulder
he's like oh my god is that naruto oh my
god
and i was like
see just scream that over your shoulder
straight up
but she was like man you need to shut up
i i didn't even know at the time i was
like oh yeah
they had like at a japanese culture club
in in in our middle school which was
supposed to be about learning about you
know japanese culture and things like
that
man they straight up turn that into an
anime club
this is crazy man it's so it's so crazy
how much influence all this stuff has
and
how big of a subculture it is it is it
is again
just watching your chat watching your
videos and seeing that stuff you know
obviously addict is
he's my resource but i you know i need
to know what's going on but it's really
cool it looks like he's got a dbz uh
poster behind him
i see a dvz in a kingdom heart i don't
know what that middle one is it looks
like full metal
uh no dbz kingdom hearts and that's a
persona five
persona oh yeah oh we got a five dollar
super chat from the wazo gamer
i saw addict's tick tock he's dancing to
carly rae jepsen
flexing the thesis building advice
addicts short shorts work on girls not
on grooming wow
okay
did you get the short versions or did
you get that we're not talking about
time time die we're going back to the l
write the deal
so another thing i want to talk about um
obviously is kind of like
you know as far as one of your bigger
videos you know obviously on the
the xbox one x the the 21 day what is it
quarantine
and yeah that just took off for you so
um
like i wanted to say like what kind of
inspired that because primarily i would
say you were primarily like a
playstation gamer and
you know not that you never played xbox
at all but you kind of went away from it
this gen
so what made you say okay let me do this
and then obviously
the um xbox all access program i believe
you mentioned time
real quick i got a two dollar super chat
from stitch ghost in the show
still the goat to me no doubt no doubt
you know this is one of the only animes
i actually ain't never watched
salute salute stitch but back back to
neil you know what i'm saying so what
talk let's talk about that one that 21
day quarantine xbox one x
yeah oh you're giving me too much credit
bro i had no idea when i made this video
i just recorded it uploaded it i went to
bed bro
really you're not trying to get the
smoke that's what he was trying to do
making an xbox video
it was immediate though because i saw it
right on my front page of youtube and i
was yeah
it's because uh um i saw it because um
one of the executives that microsoft
shared i can't remember which one
might have been them all by the end of
it uh yes i think it was major nelson i
think i saw it from him
how it came to be was um you know during
this lockdown by the time i had hit the
second month
i was kind of getting bored of
everything you know i i had exhausted
all the games that i wanted to play
reading shows i was just like i want to
do something different man so
i was on twitter and a gaming deal site
tweeted that the xbox one x was on sale
for 299. here's how you can get
zero dollars i'm like okay so i go and
look and i find the xbox all access
program you know the the short version
of it it's like a phone contract
your dollars down you just pay like
twenty dollars thirty dollars monthly
and i got the system
just to stop that was through the site
or that was yes
oh okay cool continue so that was
through this is something uh microsoft
officially does you can get it um
via amazon and they just added best buy
unfortunately right now it's kind of a
shaky given the situation so i don't
really think they're offering it but
they did say next gen
right and i do think that you know with
the xbox one and the xbox one x
i think that was like a test trial
because i think they were trying to
like get all the program exactly how
they want because i feel like they're
going to push this hardcore next gen
yeah sure yeah time give me a second yes
game over brian with the 5
super chat king i'm enjoying my new tcl
65 inch
and where's mario i don't know why
you're enjoying that but
you know mario oh my god i just see him
on the left
oh my god right there hello
at least he's
and go up those stairs now actually he
was coming downstairs he went upside
he down upstairs to get the boxes of the
knees so i'm going to have you next time
he wants to do two-hour podcast doing
nintendo direct rumors that's what he
wants
apologies deal back to you
so i got the xbox and you know this is
my first time
with uh an xbox product since 2012
because the last xbox game i played was
halo 4.
so you know it had been eight years and
i was interested to see what it was
you know what was hitting for and i
played it and i made a video saying hey
you know i had the xbox one x
i did like a 21 day challenge uploaded
that video
and then the next day i got a text
message from my brother
and it was a screenshot of a
conversation he was having with his
friends
and they sent the link in the group chat
saying yo is this your brother
hey yo and at first i was just like ah
maybe you know through friends of our
friends if our friends were friends
someone shared the video
and go and check that video it was
already at like 20 000 views
wow i'm like oh okay again i thought
nothing of it
and then literally a few hours later i
get a twitter notification
it was a tweet of my video
from major nelson saying yo really
enjoyed it this is great
and then like all these other xbox
executives start sharing it i was like
what and then literally i go back on
youtube it's already at 110 000 views i
think on
your third day and i'm just like i this
is this is going crazy
and literally i i guess what drew a lot
of people to the video was
i guess the the honesty and just
nonchalant like i have no agenda in this
i'm just going to
do a picture of xbox i gave you all my
experiences of it i still
like a lot of things about other systems
but xbox is just a great platform to
play games on but you know
just have one question for you yes i
just got one
serious question just first thing come
out of your mind when i say this who did
that for you
oh yeah i think this is this is the iron
exclusive
when when i saw the video pop up on my
timeline
right and i'm i'm watching the video
and you know my girl will pass she's
like oh oh you found somebody
i said that's not subbed to him right
now and
i said his frank candidness
and pure objectivity yes when it came to
the subject matter
was astounding at that point because
you really went there with
different thoughts and was proven
uh to to have a different view after you
finish
not saying you was right or wrong it was
just
that you was like wow this was not what
i expected
but the big thing that you did in the
beginning of that video
is you said that they allowed you to get
into an ecosystem
with no money down on something
that you were curious about
and i think that was the main selling
part
of your video because it allowed people
to understand that
you found a program that probably nobody
knew about
and you said let me see and we was like
that's probably fake right and it was
real you
and i seen the shock in your face yeah
just like and he came
and i got it and it was like yes and i
felt
real i felt you your videos made me feel
like i knew you right and it was very
personable
and you come off as a very honest
personable person
and i said you know what he definitely
has my sub
absolutely and i started watching other
videos and that's
from there just right there what i
enjoyed about i'll go ahead and uh
guys we got a two dollar super chat from
uh
squirrely dan yo mario's creeping hard
today king yeah yo he's kind of crazy
today i don't know what's going on
what i enjoyed about the video is like
a lot of people would have just focus on
the negativity it's like clearly if you
would have went on there just
got no games i don't know why i knew i
don't know why i bought this
like you know then it it would have been
like you know your standard thing but
you
you know it clearly looked like you went
into that was like look
uh this is already known i don't have to
say this for 30 right she's like
let's highlight the stuff it does have
sure it doesn't have games that's huge
it needs to improve on the quality of
games
but let's let's give people an insight
of what it does
offer right as a brand in general and
just to double down on what
king said um what i again it's funny
that king caught the same thing that i
caught which was
like we the up first of all the strength
of the video is the objectivity
and he's coming in there with no biases
all right let me just throw it on let me
see what it is uh
you know whatever right but the cool
part about it i felt is that
being king have always had this
discussion as far as the hardcore gamer
versus the majority of gamers right and
i thought what was cool was like you
kept
tabs on it you said you always kept tabs
you kept you don't look at whatever
whatever you knew
and then when a deal came that kind of
struck your nerve you're like you know
what let me try it
and i just think it highlights how
important xbox all
access is and how they need to do a
better job of promoting that
because if they can get someone like you
who again who was familiar in the 360
area with it but kind of fell away from
xbox
and say you know playstation is kind of
where i want i get these great exclusive
games
and i'm over here but if they they can
somehow manage to
push that into the forefront it's in the
mindshare
hey all access you could walk out this
store right now
i think they're doing themselves a
disservice not to promote that because
i think they'll see more situations like
yours where people will actually give
the console a chance and actually say yo
this thing actually is not that bad
for what people are saying and it
performs well and so on and so forth so
i thought that part was was pretty cool
because a lot of people are more
comfortable with going into
a store or something and just picking
something out that they want to pay for
all at once
like a lot of people are comfortable
with that absolutely
shout out to my cell phone
program i mean just to finish up on all
access it's great because at first
i was looking in the fine print like yo
where's the this guy yeah
[Music]
like i'm looking but when you break
everything down the price of the console
combined with the price of game pass
ultimate it's the exact same thing so
it's not like you're losing out so
if microsoft is smart they are going to
push this next generation and i think
they're going to
yeah if you can get someone into that
ecosystem in the beginning and let's say
council's going to be more expensive we
know that let's say that 45 50
a month that's still really good because
you'll have that paid off in like two
years time
right and then you'll own the system and
it'll be great yeah i got a question
i remember when when that was sorry king
but i remember when that was initially
being talked about
um you know a lot of people gave them a
lot of hectic because
it is technically cheaper to get that
and to get the services alongside them
than it is just to buy the console and
pay for
like regular yeah but it's a smarter way
but a lot of people don't have the
credit to do so
but the question i have for you right
did you get in
on the deal that you're able to send
your
ex back if you want a series x yeah
because that's supposed to be the
and you can ship that out and then send
you because those people that got
that's in that program has priority yes
over
everyone so i bless you not familiar
there was a different program different
than the one i have because when i
signed up they said you're able to
upgrade to
the series x after the equivalent of 18
months of payment right
when it comes to in my case because i
pay like i think 25 30 a month comes
like 300 something
right right so i mean i'm eligible if i
wanted to which i think i am going to do
once in eight
months because you know not to get into
the whole ps5 series
right now there's no incentive for me to
go and get the series nexus i just got
the one x so give them a year and a half
on all the games
yeah stop coming out for the 1x that'll
be the perfect perfect transition for
you
because you know a console is never just
the five hundred dollars you spend
like 500 in games and all that so yep
i'm fast
y'all
this is for you this is perfect shogun
with the ten dollar super chat hanging
neo i actually first found you through
your elite v2 video
and followed you ever since congrats on
your recent success
including your guest spot on unlocked
welcome to the realm brother
oh thank you thank you perfect
transition brother shout out to
everybody for i've seen a lot of
supporters in the comments thank you so
much y'all
perfect transition because that's
literally what's gonna ask you like next
and it's just like
let's talk about that magic moment
brother like oh man you know
like i i call it like the equivalent of
being called up
to the big leagues you're saying like
you got the call
you're saying lord ryan mccaffrey the
whole you know like it's like the espn
the video games in a way we've all been
watching them for a long time
so what was it like to get that call to
to be
up there celebrate it with your peers
you know and just just
the whole magic the spectacle of being
on ign unlocked
your boy neil gainsmark so
how this all came to be is um there were
a lot of people
in the comment section saying like yo
you need to get on this podcast you need
to get on that podcast and i'm always
like
hey if you guys want me to get on a
podcast just hit up the
respective podcast creators and we'll
work something out yes people
i don't know if this is coordinator or
not but i'm tweeting at ryan mccaffrey
get neo on get neo on and i keep in my
mentions and i'm like all right whatever
and then
i get a follow from ryan mccaffrey
[Applause]
and i'm like hi okay let's see what this
is and i you know i retweeted that
person's comments saying
hey ryan mccaffrey let's set something
up and he's like sure i'd love to have
you on i'm like oh
all right let's get it so
start we start coordinating um times and
i was like
yeah we'll set something up because you
know they they produce episodes like
yeah out at a time into scheduling so
i wasn't expecting anything until they
hit me up um the day before saying yo
last minute can you be on a lock
tomorrow and i was like all right sure
i'll get on the phone
and we go on and it was so funny and why
that episode was so significant is
the news about halo infinite
literally during the recording of the
podcast and ryan was like yo
we got big news right now i haven't told
anybody halo infinite got delayed so it
was like kind of a genuine reaction from
everybody but
how it came to be um and and i always
say this i try
to be a hundred percent transparent and
humble it happened because of the
amazing
members of the community and
you know like i always say you know like
i put in the work but it's the people
who really appreciate it and that will
be the story that's told
you know from you know now until the end
of time so i have
nobody to thank but all the amazing
folks that made that happen and it's a
testament to you it's a testament to
your hard work and it's a testament
again like you said to your community
that says you know what you would be a
great representative to be
on the show you know and it's also
salute to them too for for you know
actually following through you know
because sometimes we
as smaller content creators sometimes
you feel like damn you know you wish i
got a shot sometimes or whatever but to
see it
you know was really refreshing to see so
absolutely
i will i will say this though just a big
shout out to ryan mccaffrey in terms of
in terms because i mean we've we've seen
this all throughout especially the past
couple months with representation and
all that
yes brian mccaffrey has been one of the
better allies that we've had in terms of
giving people a shot on the show like
he's followed through and he's put
on um which more than i can say about
some of the other stuff
you know you know where we come from and
like i said
it's refreshing it's so refreshing to
see that and and
yeah continue because you know well um
the way he represented himself there
yeah and represented our community yes
it was uh it was a moment because i i
saw it on unlock and it popped up and i
was like they got my man right there
right i was like did he go right there
salute i i tuned in
i watched a little bit of it and i was
like that's what i'm talking about right
there absolutely you know 100
professionals
bro that was dope so we gonna move on
but um gotta ask the question that we
ask
all the members of the realm when they
come here
lord neo i need your top five
video games or franchises of all
time no pressure oh yeah
i get this question asked at least every
stream
i don't know if i keep changing it but a
few of them so
my all-time favorite uh rpg
he's got to be chrono trigger yo
my boy your boss is going to love you
right now chronograph strong
trigger that like to me there hasn't
been anything that's reached the same
pinnacle of that
in addition to that these go back and
forth and it's kind of funny because of
their numbers yeah you know
flipping one way or another final
fantasy x and final fantasy 9.
i don't need all that extra woo from you
sir he didn't have seven but we're gonna
forget that we gonna forgive him
yeah yeah let's go let's go to this rap
super chat real quick
from brat salute lords
god that new brat look lobo t-shirt mad
love to the eye open
you know what he's talking about
absolutely for being messy
wow so we got okay so you got the chrono
trigger you said that flips between
final fantasy 6 and final fantasy
nine okay so that go that'll go to two
spot okay cool
right three uh so number three i would
have to say
oh man i just got i gotta give it to cd
projekt gods the witcher three
oh no is loving you right now
right now it's like seoul's all-time
favorite yeah yeah you're just spitting
you know this is a permanent solved
guess
that iron bank does not dish out payment
it received payment
chrono trigger 56 witcher 3.
all right then all right so i mean
because i'm a big big rpg player i mean
that's that's kind of the reason why i
only complete like three games a year
because they're all like 200 plus power
games
um but i would say like just just to mix
it up uh one of my other all-time
favorite games devil may cry 3.
okay on the switch and they added in a
bunch of new content
yo i don't know who said this to happen
but thank you wait hold on what
classroom you played that old sir
oh buddy yeah yeah what platform is that
sure i just want you to repeat that for
the for the masses because they need
that don't you dare hey you don't have
to fool me
what platform you know don't don't
listen
i just want to hear lord neil repeat
what platform is that sir oh he's going
to get his switch man this is
bull okay all right right here
switch coming in hot let's go he
he officially left the podcast so let's
kick him out
let me ask you a question so um before
you was using your switch you didn't
need glasses
uh chrono cross is greater than chrono
trigger that is easy
it is kind of a hot mess but nah come on
now yeah we might have to throw the lure
on that one
see this is why i hate doing the top
five because for me everything in my top
ten is kind of like interchangeable yeah
james i love so much but if i if i had
to pick
one more game to throw into that just
one just just one
more all right so this game
it ranks lower on my top 10 list but
i've already hit so many rpgs so i'm not
going to
throw that into the mix i'm gonna have
to say
dino crisis wow first
wow why dino crisis i gotta hear this
so okay so gr like there were a lot of
games growing up to me that
they really affected me in my formative
years and you know as a kid growing up
you know oh i love dinosaurs i love
jurassic park i love all these things
and then to play that from capcom i'm
just like yep i'm sold
like i i don't know out there with all
these resident evil spin-offs that
they're making and
dinosaurs plus high def graphics why why
don't you give this to us
yeah that is true what about that i
think it was at the microsoft game cup
uh third-party show they showed like
some dinosaur almost like i had a dino
crisis feel to it did you know what i'm
talking about it was it was
it was the one that looked like turok it
was um co-op
dinos i forgot the name of it but i'll
get you the information um
neil i'll let you check it out it's not
like dying on craigslist it's not like
all right i was the first person shooter
yeah right
third person resident evil horror with
dinosaurs i didn't like what they did
later on with the turning them into
robots type of thing
dino crisis okay what happens off no no
that that yeah that that robot stuff was
weird
and the final question i got which is
favorite console of all time any
generation
oh
okay yeah this is all right it
definitely is it definitely is feel free
to say that xbox one x yeah
hi feel free to get the check
xbox game pass because it gives you
access to all the games
[Laughter]
shogun is second extension is the name
of the game
but i need that console man from your
entire gaming history what's the most
you know the thing that's the most
passionate to you that you hold dear
which console
i would have to say the playstation 2
bro you know
being an rpg being an rpg guy and also
because
you know if you go back and look at like
the playstation 2's like first two
three years bro bangers that came on it
the amount of free time that started
bro so for me i would have to say
playstation 2 because of the
variety of the games that existed and a
lot of um franchises that i still play
today i mean dove my cry for example of
course
um but yeah i mean right behind that is
going to have to be the super nintendo
um
okay okay okay listen man no you can't
go wrong
two has come up a lot i would say solve
probably playstation
probably the most i would say right the
most yeah absolutely i mean it's the
i mean you have like a ten year tail on
that that
that console man like so many people got
a chance to experience that and
like you said like there's so many
franchises got their start on ps2
i mean it's undeniable neil was you a
day one dude on the playstation 2
like did you make the line and sleep out
for two days and stuff like that
ps2 is hard to get in the city bro i i
wish i wish i was like that um
it was literally a case of i would i was
basically at the um
like anything my parents said so if i
wanted that console to be like oh no you
got to wait for christmas or
so i didn't get a ps2 i remember i got
it within like the first year and a half
yeah we had to return our unit because
it was defective
oh oh we returned it and then we were
just like
well are they going to get any
playstation 2's in soon and they're just
like no that was the last one so
we had christmas well we didn't have to
wait till christmas but my mom was like
wait till christmas i was like okay so
waited to christmas
we got a ps2 2000 so just out of
curiosity did
did your moms get you a christmas for a
ps2 for two christmases
it's like it's like you got it the first
one then you had to take it back he's
like wait for christmas again
we had got it in the in the summer
because um
my sister and i we both had made like
straight a's
yeah we made straight a's right we get a
ps2
that unit's defective and then we'll uh
we'll just get
get it later and we ended up waiting for
christmas but you know they made it
worth a while when we got it for
christmas
so uh we got the ps2 we got dragon ball
z budokai the first
between kingdom hearts one and two
mm-hmm
it was something to see where they were
making sure that they stood on the
cutting edge that's cd
we've got 108 dragons with the ten
dollar super chat lord lemethius is in
the building shout out to the lord's
incognito name is officially changed
to the switch police and get those
hockey sticks ready i will be in the
penalty box for sure
you already know yeah that's uh that's
letting everybody know that who uh
purchased those custom hockey jerseys um
i'm fedexing them
out on monday yeah so um i was uh
debating on who to do it with like it
was what i got
going to go with uh the united states
postal service
being all the stuff that they're going
under right now i'm not gonna even mess
with them
um because i want everybody y'all waited
a long time this culvert stuff did some
stuff
so i was gonna go with either uh fedex
or ups
and fedex is right down the hill from me
and they gave me a better deal
so i'm those in the room we'll put that
special order in lord le meteos you know
you wanted them i see disappearing a
couple people in there
yeah those are coming like i said king
put that out there so that's dope you
already know
but um so we're gonna move on with the
show i know uh lord neil his time may be
limited so you let us
know if you could rock or if you got a
goal it's all good nothing we're kicking
out
you don't see it ah nah nah we we we're
good
i moved some things around so we oh man
perfect perfect so we're gonna move on
man so we're gonna get into last week's
poll
the last week's poll results are in and
the people have spoken to the question
with the recently delayed delay of halo
infinite what do you think microsoft
should do to help alleviate the loss of
the title
during the series x launch the choices
are and the winner are
is of our close four eight highway our
people at 39
damn 30 that was really close was by
wb games and bungie
give the base hope for the future
coming in at second at 24 was signed a
big third party
exclusive to game pass for uh series x
launch
in third place at 23 yo this is mad
close all three at 23
of the vote was halo delay was the right
call
launched the series x as is group and in
last place and only 13
of the vote was i don't care but if i
see craig again in a delayed halo
infinite
throw three four three in the bushes
so that was what's your thoughts on this
song
listen i mean it's funny to me that the
number one answer is the one that makes
them
spend the most amount of money it's like
yeah just go by wb you know
so i mean hey there's been a lot of
marketing
that felt like it was like in hand
hand-in-hand with wb
and microsoft especially like after
fandom this week it was weird like
a lot of stuff so nothing came of that
that we know of right at least not yet
so we'll see um but for me honestly
the answer is to me if
go up to cd projekt red right either
make king's world
uh happy as hell and and
and break the bank and and bring that on
to game pass or at the very least
say listen guys what do you need from us
to get that series x patch out
at launch mm-hmm right solve that that
deal is done already
why we we're talking about deals of of
the different magnitude
brother wb and i honestly
believe there's something to that but
again
as believable as microsoft would be they
would be
they would do what i would do right they
will give you a compliment and smack you
in the mouth at the same time
so they will let you have batman they
will let you have suicide on
your platform the same time that we do
but it will be also in game pass for
free but you have to pay the fee
and i think that is a beautiful thing
because they wouldn't want to cut them
off
from everybody else because i think
everybody should experience those games
no doubt so if you want to get these
before you get to the top yeah we have
shroom king with the two dollar super
chat one option should have been send us
to me
shout out to the lords and hoping you
guys have a blessed day newfound nukem
set up a great community game last night
ps3 was lit though
play casters getting real podcasters to
play game with each other
we i was on that with ainsley a couple
of the guys so salute to those guys just
doing that do it on another day don't do
it
on saturday we can get it i
when it's three o'clock that's pizza top
right
so lord attic you are up now sir uh four
guys man
what is going on with this game man
let's talk to us time
oh no cat daddy look at the five dollar
super chat
on purpose man
and the teaser trailer had for the movie
uh looking like a blend of dark knight
and
seven fire yeah we got the fan
on topic we're gonna get to it so
okay um when it comes to you know i i
would say that
there are games out there that just blow
up like not necessarily
for no reason but it's just a lot of
good circumstances that all come
together
and it just makes for one of like an
experience that just blows up in the
industry in general
and i think we're on upon our next one
and i think that game is fall guys
because it doesn't seem like it's
slowing down whatsoever
uh it's been out for about a month
hasn't it it and it just
it feels like this is one of those games
that is going to
push this whole thing because i feel
like now because this game's successful
you have everyone trying to make party
games
to be honest i'm cool with that because
i've always loved party games but
uh you know we don't really get a whole
lot of quality once
and the one thing that you know this
showed me is nintendo lost the bag
because this could have been them
with mario i like the resolution though
yeah you're ridiculous
hold on we got we got spiderman with the
five dollars yeah
we're going to own the video game space
wb hold my beard batman gotham knight is
fire
they busted a gun for sure for sure
but when it comes to this game this fall
guys game
i think that there's nothing like it on
the market i think that's one of the
reasons that
it really is captivated i think their
social media presence is lit
and i think they're one of the we have
we finally have our wendy's gaming
outlet yeah like i have never seen
since it's like a party type of game
i've never seen a
twitter quite like this like they were
literally going to this
big entity that was on twitter uh that
was on twitch that
was trying to win one crown because he
he didn't win one crown
and they started trolling him for like
three days
it was funny that would like tweet like
if he gets to a final round they're like
he we think he's got it this time then
like 10 minutes later never mind
and they did this for three days
straight
and i feel like this is one of those
games that
you know it's like i said it's going to
push there's going to be a bunch of
different party games that what i wanted
to bring the realm is
these type of successful games do you
think that
what the success well first off i want
to bring it up
the biggest shame to this is it's not on
xbox or
switch
doesn't care about switch but guess what
there's millions
millions of gamers that have it but
katie
and what i want what i wanted to bring
to the realm
is with the amount of success this game
has
do you think it's going to live up to
maybe like because i i think it's not
necessarily like on fortnight levels
but i do think it's going to have a lot
of success and you know it's going to
spawn a whole bunch of different games
in this genre
and i i think it it might be like a like
a
shadow of what fortnite would like i do
think it's going to get it's
just going to get more popular as time
goes by because it
it can appeal to you know a what
i'm looking for it could appeal to a
younger audience it can put an older
audience it doesn't really have a
demographic that it stands on
and i i just wanted to ask you now i
don't know who here has played it
is you're the only one that's played it
neo because i don't know if anyone else
feedback on this time only been two
people here y'all haven't played fall
guys
it's my fault because i'm playing goes
to tsushima and destiny's
i'm doing some grinding stuff in
destination i've been taking my time
but as far as soft i don't know sorry i
don't know
yeah so the only person is literally on
two so let's give it
to neil neal talk to us about this thing
man all right so
i actually jumped into fall guys late by
comparison to most people i only started
playing it last week
what's funny is you started playing it
like two weeks after it come out and
that's late like
that's how big it is like i feel like if
you didn't jump on this one because i
remember when it first came out he was
like oh god small guys small guys i'm
like
what is this game like i had no idea
so i jumped into it and i was doing like
a random stream for twitch i was like
all right let's see what this game is
all about
i was only going to stream like 20
minutes bro i was streaming that for
over an
hour i know i saw it was on my timeline
yeah having so much fun like is that
um i want to shout out somebody in the
comments right now because um
yeah christopher hart anybody who has
not played fall guys yet go play it and
try to stop after one round i dare you
that is true because it's always
just one more game one more game it
designed it
um and have it set up is like even if
you get eliminated you can ex
start up a new round and it's very quick
and seamless but it's fun
it definitely it um it scratches that
mario party itch which
you know i know mario you standing over
there on the steps
[Laughter]
how nintendo and this is what i don't
understand about nintendo nintendo they
can put out any game and this thing will
sell eight million copies facts how do
they put out a mario party
in this day and age on the switch
a broken and busted online interface
it goes nowhere like that was supposed
to be yeah
guys you know like keep it going keep it
updates
and fall guys it just it unintentionally
or not
it filled that void and i love it for it
because that's that type of accessible
game
absolutely the sad part is i feel like
nintendo might have just killed the
mario party franchise because i know
people are still going to play mario
party obviously but i do feel like if
this game evolves and they get a bunch
of mini games
if they drop another mario party there's
going to be a lot of people like why do
i need
mario party fall guys is way better if
you didn't learn anything from nintendo
nintendo kills nothing all right
i'm gonna tell you right now no matter
what they do they're impervious to
any type of uh real hurt and i mean
they've they've
shot themselves in the foot millions of
times and they have come back like jason
voorhees
over and over again so no at no point in
time they don't care
if they don't own that entity outright
they don't care about that game
and they probably ask them or whatever i
don't know what's the deal that went
down
i don't know how it's just on
playstation and this is the reason why i
would say it will not it's all pieces
will not be anywhere close to uh
fortnight this is why right
fortnight is everywhere right period
right period
you get it on your cell phone please the
epic and these dudes is fighting right
now over fortnite
it's it's a whole different beast is
that it's free to play and it's
everywhere
now this is in one and i'm talking about
a console space
and don't even talk about my pc my pc is
for work here it is
um microsoft get your stuff together so
i can get my series x up there
um but at the same time
i can see this game being a hit for that
playstation though
and i it streams so well
everybody i see play it their eyes are
lighting up and they're having so much
fun i've seen a lot of pairs playing
and she was having a good time and you
were having a good time
and then i saw a couple other guys
happen and i'm like wow it really looks
like so much fun too bad it's not in
game pass i'm like
everyone having a good time made you
feel like you even wanted it remotely
do you see hey bro yo he gotta control
everyday
but i feel we i feel we coming from
bottom let's get that super
we got the wise old gamer with the two
dollar super chat apparently neo
borrowed addicts tcl
mike mike is lit
with my man mike what's going on what's
the back story behind this
okay so i called the playstation gamer
the cheap gamer
right and i i said that they all have
tcl televisions
and they make sure that they get them on
black friday oh my
god and they get it at the double down
deal
so so just just out of curiosity like
clarify you've never bought a tv on
black friday
no no no no never
wait wait i buy them after the ces
show i put my money down when they're
coming out are you positive
i got money yeah no no no no no it's
just i'm i'm one of those
uh video files that actually uh
like quality televisions so so the
quality goes down just because it's
cheaper
are you pocket watching no i'm not i'm
just trying to get i'm trying to get a
realm of the king's brain
he's acting like if you buy it on black
friday and decoy out of the corner
if you go to a store and they have a two
hundred dollar television
on the wall do you think that's how
that's they're gonna be the best that
you're gonna get
we're not talking about a 200 on the
wall we're talking about black friday
where fifteen hundred dollars like nine
hundred so
just because the 600 is black that means
it's not
less i'm not getting stuck i don't want
nobody's leftover stock removed
you don't feel that
so there's no such thing as being a
smart consumer
listen you your price you know
all right so check it out this is what
you did right you purchased the
television
no no no no let me split this deal let's
say we both go to the store i got to
remove this mic
yeah right so you personally i'm not
saying that you purchased a cheat tv
just say me and you both go to the store
and if you get the black you get the
black friday deal right
you get the black friday deal now you
purchased last gen television
now when this x and this playstation 5
come out
my tv can play that stuff yo tv you
gotta double down now now your little
nine hundred dollar purchase then turns
into two thousand and some change
cuz you gotta go get ready you gotta
find somebody to sell your tv to
and you gotta go buy another tv and if
you can't sell your tv
then that tv comes becomes the look at
you acting like these are
cheap tv so
just like curiosity real quick before we
time because then we're about the time
so have you ever bought anything on
black product uh
no no no no no no no no
no no we're gonna go through the lines
have you ever bought anything on black
friday yes i have but i want to add
yeah good i want to add something all
right so so you buy everything
full price essentially right well um
like let's
depend on those really messy right now
it depends on certain things now like if
you're going to say something like a
value let's say game pass i know where
you're going
um so listen let's say i wasn't even
going to go there
but let's just let's just say right in
any given year
if i was let's say game pass didn't
exist any given year
i have to go through my list of games
and pick out games that i'm going to
purchase
right because i'm not going to get all
willy-nilly and just become a collector
i got games that's still in the plastic
i hated that i hated what i became i
became somebody that started putting my
games on the shelf
and and wasn't the player because you
noticed that you said you play rpgs
you play rpgs and you said maybe you
finished two three games a year right
yeah but you still purchasing more games
as they come out right
right game pass allows me to not worry
about purchasing that stuff
allowing me to try everything i want to
try
and save money there so there that's why
i'm a frugal
consumer certain things in my lifestyle
i will not be frugal with so
i will not go with my car i will not be
frugal with my television
i will not be frugal with my food and i
damn sure it won't be frugal with my
collectibles you have selective
frugalness
but you should be but you'll you you'll
be frugal with your games got you
continuing
but then time and left leg hold it
before we got an ideal get his response
off didn't solve can you get the chance
oh oh no no i was literally just asking
the question oh you just asked oh god
he just wanted to see the smoke he was
understanding the world
continues we got stitched
with the recent breakdown of the xbox
series soc why hasn't sony shown
anything about their architecture
other than ssd do you think sony fears
the reaction of gamers
thoughts uh i don't think sony that's
not a narrative they're going to win
so why even go down you know what don't
listen to solve you know what stitch
you're on
then we have shroom kingdom with the 2
super chat king buy the prototype from
the king by the prototype from the
manufacturer
tv
then we got aeronauts with the uh hold
on
yeah we eroded mr fight off some attack
king fraud and buying tv
day and date but won't play a game until
it's in game
shots but you can also use it this way
financially i can't afford it if i'm
paying 10 grand
when
no there are smart consumers and there
are fools okay
okay and we have people with tcls
what's funny is you guys be acting like
this black friday isn't one of the
biggest shopping holidays of the year
there's too much smoke that day i don't
care i'm not doing it no i'm not doing
it i just don't know
why i just hold up yeah
let's get real you know they aren't
putting any of the fire tvs on sale for
black friday all you gonna see is
westinghouse
you know i'm gonna get you right now
jonathan i know
for a fact that cognito got his fire tv
on black friday so eat that
shout out to our king we do not buy
those tvs that say manager special i'm
rocking
for life
i think i'm caught up
but i'm not i'm generally not buying a
tv on black friday because it's like
when you go there right first of all the
the deer
the the the door buster on sale those
are the icelands sensors in the tcl's
those are the ones that people fight for
they had over i don't know why
um but that's just the stuff you see
people on twitter they do be putting
these tvs on sale
last friday it's got my phone you guys
have a tv
i would say that for high-end tvs you i
need a fight
more than likely you see them on sale
before the super bowl then you find one
right now
yeah yo he don't he got a tv hey right
no
yo we literally clowned our own mate
our own friend when he got a high skin
he
never made that mistake no game no i'm
gonna be out there
i'm your friend i'm that friend and then
what happened was i got clowns so bad
that i went out of my way to outdo all
of everybody
with the five listen i get it all i'm
saying is that yo if this if it's a hot
this is where i agree with attic if it's
a high-end tv and i'm about to pick it
up anyway and black friday got 200
off and they gonna mail it to me i'm not
gonna be in the store elbowing dudes
i'm not doing that you know what i'm
saying but like like neo said when best
buy hit me with the two weeks ahead of
time
you're ordering online chilling the
house and they come to you yeah
i mean i don't know
i don't know that you see those deals on
those type of tvs black friday as
opposed to right before the super bowl
you got to get down with best buy
brother you got to get that yeah
trust me that's why that's fine they're
not doing that yeah look at that look at
that i'm doing that
you're just not doing it okay okay
all right now we got to go
that is the roundabout answer to the tcl
question yeah
we got time we got five dollar
supercharger
enjoying the petty af i'm not going to
say the whole thing because we got it
the young lords man the young pocket
watching also do not do black friday nor
do i buy tlc's keep your
pickles raised with slipping that your
pinky
four guys oh guys listen um i think i i
don't know about that fortnite argument
i i think it's cool
but it's gonna it's gonna come down to
content right right um eventually people
get tired of the stages that are there
they're going to need
new uh interesting content to keep
people engaged but that said
not since fortnight have i seen a game
that appeals to
a broad spectrum of people right as this
game um
and that that that's where i actually
got you uh i don't have you but uh just
to add something to your conversation
thursday they're announcing season two
okay there you go
listen uh my my wife's little cousin
who's probably seven eight years old
just recently just started a youtube
channel and
he and he's basically playing fall guys
wow and
again he's he's he's a young kid doesn't
like he's
he's very articulate loves talking he's
playing fall guys he's playing the game
and he's talking through as he's playing
um so this is a this is i know it's
going to appeal to a vast
like a a large scope of people and
that's going to give it legs in a way
that
um but i i still don't think it touches
the fortnite thing unless
it goes everywhere right i don't think
it's it's gonna like you know
necessarily touch fortnite in terms of
how big it got just because it's not
free to play
yeah but but i do think that you know if
you go
back in time with around the same time
duration that fortnight and this game
have
like i i do think this game has more
going for it
because they've seen the fortnights
they've seen the apex legends they've
seen how they need to
formally do this type of game now right
yeah no doubt
and not to mention that the people
making this game seem to be you know in
touch
like it's like i said they're always on
twitter they're in touch with what their
community wants
yeah i mean to go to who's making the
game and supporting the game and
publishing the game i got to give a big
shout out devolver man
already you know they've already signed
that check and sent that to them
but they they just they can pick winners
man they
really yeah they can see they can see
things in games and maybe other people
just aren't paying attention to the fact
and they put their full force behind
them i mean
you know hotline miami with carrying
with obviously my friend
pedro like the messenger all these games
um
so shout out to them because this is
this is as big a success as they've ever
seen yet let me jump in i think i
figured kate got his bars off right and
referenced this
yeah yeah yeah now i'll just make it
quick um i wanna i gotta give a shout
out man to the home team man lords of
gaming.net gotta shout out
lord gene because we were at pax and
i remember king me you were giving out
the assignments
and as far as coverage what everybody's
gonna cover you know interviews setting
up with devs
and i remember four guys came up with a
thing and i got front like i looked at
it i was like
who's this for like i didn't get it like
i just be like i didn't get it
but i'll never forget his enthusiasm he
was like yo [ __ ] i want to cover that
you know he got the interview with the
dev he set it up he wrote tremendous
article he did try this for the website
by the way
but that was that was another thing but
i want to salute him because
he saw the vision like he was definitely
onto something
and it was just amazing and it was so
crazy because i remember laughing at him
we had a
an article where it was kind of like the
most anticipated game for 2020. like he
he was so far ahead of this thing and
i'm laughing and i'm like okay what
happened
do you think this okay cool and to watch
this thing
take off in the manner that it is taking
off
is truly remarkable so like so i've said
shout out to devolver
they definitely have some type of
nuances where they could literally
see and feel what's about to blow and be
a hit
and um yeah this they got young people
when they're doing
you're ridiculous that was guys old man
shaving i see what you doing no no they
definitely did because when we
we we talked to the guys that was there
they were definitely on the younger side
except for the dude that was real
condescending and kind of oh yeah
yeah yeah but um other than that it was
really good shout out to media tonic man
i mean they really killed it and his
exact words he said cog legend told me
he's like yo
remember how when we first saw rocket
league this is going to be the next
joint and i was like okay and i started
taking this and since then
it's just been going on it's a phenom
for a playstation shout out to them for
snatching it up
yeah and put it in ps plus that was a
smart move and now you know it's a small
team from my understanding so it'll
actually
you know once they get their bearings
and do their stuff they'll eventually
probably put it out on xbox one
and uh but and switch but again salute
to them so if you want to get those
before you move on
yes sir we got a five dollar super chat
from stitch if your tv
is cheaper than your monitor something
is wrong
on the tc i was like playing on a switch
your eyes just hurt
that we're gonna need we're gonna need
hogan in a minute um we
got philly eagle with the five dollar
super chat definitely not a game for me
however chalk up another point for
gaming diversity
diversity is king that is brother
preacher brother
then we have spitty smith with the five
dollar super chat four guys came out of
nowhere just like rocket league did so
you know i i definitely want to really
give a shout out to like sony because
like it's like
they're like they saw that and they're
like yo someone's in the chat yeah like
right
now like what's in the chat because to
be real could you imagine if that was on
game pass
like that would really help like they've
gotta listen you could never tell what's
gonna hit with these games
right so i'm not gonna blame game out
all you guys but don't
disney okay yeah at this point no no no
the hell with it being on game pass oh
god right and i'm gonna say this i'm
gonna say this
the hell would it be it needed to be on
playstation now
why because playstation now numbers is
two million
all right here we go there we go
it's on playstation plus not playstation
now
but that's not just that playstation now
so it's on playstation plus yeah
good so only two percent of the debate
table but
i know that people downloaded it
i say they definitely
needed it over there for their services
all right because when microsoft is
being just touted as services
i believe that this is a great thing to
make a pair let's say
me let's say i get pressured by you
because you did if y'all don't see the
dm's
pressure the community want us to play
with them
this is the bs i gotta put up with this
is it right here they told me yo
okay so we're gonna do a community play
this is the game right
i said oh okay cool is it a game pass
just like that
just like that he said no you got to get
a playstation i said i'm not doing that
i left the chat right so then and then
they they put it yo so even if we
purchase it you know for you to you know
to play the month you're not going to
i said no stop doing that stop making me
do things that i don't want to do
so the pressure is so high right now
because it's at a point right now i
gotta try the ecosystem thank you so
much
if i'm gonna play with you i'm gonna
play with attic i'm gonna play with
other people and we're streaming at the
same time yep
what type yo do you know the memes they
will have on me on the playstation right
now
cause i have my camera on oh lit
just out of curiosity first off it's on
pc so don't use that excuse me second
i'm gonna use my pieces
um i just have a quick question for you
and your personal opinion this is no
like this is no shady stuff do you think
that
might it not being on the microsoft
platform is hurting them right now
yes okay and you do think it it's okay
okay i believe any game that's a hit
someplace else that's not on your
your console of choice is hurting your
your console choice
and i do think that if this game win
this game because i do think it's going
to i don't know how long but when this
game comes out
like microsoft needs to drop that bag
and be like this is going in game pass
day one
because because at this point it's like
i said
everyone is playing in the carnival and
the only people ain't there is the xbox
people hey switch stop trying
like switches oh you mean the market
leader
you mean the market leader yeah those
guys yeah okay
yeah those guys those guys the guys that
win mpd you mean
you mean the people who had abandoned
the platform like five years early
because of failure no no listen
listen they're winning right now i
wasn't there i wasn't there for that i'm
here for this
[Laughter]
need to drop the bag to get kane to play
for that yo listen let me tell you
something you don't did this already you
don't got me a tattoo on my chest
you're squirrely yo somebody blocked
squirrels
what the hell let's ask you a question
real quick we will make this long
yes time we get 300 likes and three
podcasts oh back to back you'll you'll
try fall guys
if that i can get 300 likes in this
podcast today
i'll do it all
oh
my faithful will not hit that button
so
success depends on how fast they can get
it on other platforms and how fast they
go free to play
and the ability to scale with content
that is true
i mean but not everybody has epic money
to be able to do that
so um it's gonna be interesting but i
think we're very much one of twenty
dollars they'll be fine
yeah that's true you can spend twenty
dollars at mcdonald's man i think
they're gonna be fine
ridiculous what else all right we're
good we're gonna support
you all right let us move on damn
anyway moving on lord solved man
something went down in the description
what it is
he wants to get to his talking yeah
y'all killing my joy
what's funny is is my talk will be last
all the time and i'd ever say no but
cognitive wants to talk about this he
hasn't shut up about it
i make your topic first or not see all
right
we got love today so yeah um yesterday
was the beginning of dc
fandom uh before we talk about any
specifics
bend the knee to dc this
has to be the largest media dump
of stuff i have ever seen yeah over the
course of 24 hours
it is it was less than that but they
they repeated it a few times
um wow wow wow everything that has been
lacking out of all of these other sort
of game shows
during uh during the time of pandemic we
understand
it's been difficult to be able to do
shows as you've done in the past
but dc sort of waited and held on to
everything and just
dropped everything in one and one ball
if you're not into gaming if you're not
in whatever you're into
they spoke about something that you like
no so uh
shout out to them that was fantastic and
actually i think today there is actually
more new content
about about shows and stuff like that
not necessarily movie stuff
and um and then i think in september
there's a part
two where they're just gonna add more
stuff in addition to that so
um shout out to dc yeah um i think
marvel needs to look at them and
uh especially during this time and how
do we put out this information in a way
that's that that's cool for fans
and it it it's obvious that they really
they really thought about how they were
going to present this
and overall was fantastic um so let's
talk about the big things in general um
so we're going to talk about the gaming
stuff but we are going to speak
generally about what we liked about the
movie stuff coming out obviously the
snyder cut
what was was kind of huge um we'll be
seeing that soon later this year
we got the wonder warm 1984 trailer yeah
we um what else do we get
we
we got the cast of the new suicide squad
movie we got black adam teases
aquaman shazam two we got sandman
we got more titan stuff um
static shock i mean like i said it was
so much stuff so um let's let's focus on
the
on the big guns right so uh king and i
had discussed that i was really hopeful
for batman he won
and i really respect you you you brother
you i bend the knee to you sir so what
is it you called you called the whole
batman thing
yeah he called everything everything
that that he's talking about he called
it all if you look at the chat
he called everything wow um you know
because they did worry that you weren't
gonna see
batman at all um but then when i saw it
at the end of the presentation i'm like
it's gotta be something they're gonna
show us something
um what we got was like a two and a half
minute trailer of of
emo batman and i'm i'm all in on emo
batman
i'm all the way in on emo batman go
twilight let's do this
i think the biggest thing that they
really need is they need someone that
plays both roles really well
and i think marvel's really good i think
that's
the biggest thing that separates marvel
and dc
is marvel most the time they're one hit
wonder they get the
the person that's right for the job
almost the first time
and it doesn't seem like dc does i mean
we're on like with the third fourth
batman like the third fourth superman
like
yeah so uh real quick before we get into
the game stuff what did you guys think
about the movie stuff that was talked
about the batman anything else you guys
might have drawn you guys let's get neo
in man yeah yeah of course so i gotta
say like echoing what you said
in terms of all these events that
they've had going on dc fandom was the
best
like it literally encapsulated
everything like it made me feel like i
was watching comic-con yeah you know i i
was kind of worried at first when they
announced that like oh these panels are
gonna be like five to ten minutes
realistically i was thinking they're
just gonna get on there and say hey we
got this and that's it but no they had a
lot of stuff so i commend them for that
they did a great job
so um looking at the movie stuff i mean
for the things that we already know
like wonder woman and all that stuff i
wasn't really too interested in
but i gotta say i'm really digging what
we're getting out of uh the suicide
squad because you know it's james gunn
i'm a big fan of his work
big time so i like what they're doing
with that i can't wait to see it i think
dc
navi dc that was the funniest thing in
the world like the second that uh
disney had fired him they were straight
up in his dms like yo
yeah let's go so i think that was great
i think i think the movie will turn out
great
um the batman i mean i'm sure we'll
we'll save that for a little bit later
but
that looks phenomenal you know matt
because we're going to get him about
enough
you're probably going to get into the
gaming stuff more so oh yeah yeah sure
so um
like the second matt reeves was
announced as director i i thought it was
a great move i love what he did with the
apes movies
and this is looking more like a year two
version of batman where you know he's
got a little bit of experience not a lot
and i just like how you know it's not
really shying away
from a lot of the comic booky type of
elements like it's still grounded
it's still dark it's still gritty but
there's you can still tell you're
watching
a movie about a guy who dresses up like
a bat and they don't they don't they
don't like shirk away from that trying
to say oh this is what we're doing
um so i thought it was cool i just think
it's weird though because
with dc i know like what they're
focusing on right now is just to make
good movies because you know for a while
they weren't doing that um
but it's kind of strange though because
you have like three different visions
going around you have like the ellsworth
tales which is like joker
and then this new the batman movie then
you have
like this little pocket of the universe
that's connected to the the old dc eu
which is like the suicide squad wonder
woman aquaman but they don't have that
much connection
and then you have the snyder cut which
is just full on old continuity and then
i don't know where they're going with
this like if one of them is a success
they're going to try to continue that so
like let's just say if this snyder
causes a success
maybe they might keep ben affleck for
more things and just say hey this is all
the moments
he did sound sign on for something else
but um
are you familiar with do you read comics
are you familiar with
uh all right so i believe and this is
just
based on no facts whatsoever the way
that dc is set up and they're set up in
a multiverse type of thing that they
can't have multiple batmans and multiple
uh looks uh because of the multiverse
with right what marvel is trying to do
is they're trying to emulate that type
of formula dc already started that with
the tv shows
so a lot of times you know people's
things are actually really good too
fantastic stuff a lot of times people
are asking what's canon and what's not
canon
being the fact that they're not clear on
what's canon or what
universe is the main earth one right
i think your your your assessment of it
is true because if the snyder cut does
take off
do they make that earth prime earth one
and then everything else that spawns
from that is part of the multiverse
even though they did crisis and was
breaking down stuff though yeah but yeah
go ahead i'm sorry i'm just like yeah
when you were saying it like it was
making hell of a lot of sense
yeah it's 100 accurate because i mean at
the end of the day if you look at it
like okay
we'll probably get a good batman movie a
good wonderland movie and a wonder woman
movie and i think
realistically the snyder cut there's no
way it could be worse than what i saw
with you
i i because i waited a while to watch
justice league i was like
go watch that i watched on hbo max bro
that is one of the worst
i'd rather i'd rather watch batman
versus superman ten times than watch
justice league and just think it's a
two-hour movie
but um in terms of all the movie stuff
i'm excited for it i think
we're in for like we're in a better
place now with dc stuff than we were
like four years ago so don't you feel
like they're xbox
oh my god
they don't got their teeth kicked in so
they had to get these stuff together
i don't know i i i mean phil spencer
hasn't given us a batman yet you know
he's saying like we haven't gotten any
of that all we hear is
the same old yeah listen
let's get attic man what did you think
about all that
uh we have jd game with the five dollar
super chat pub g versus fortnight with
twenty dollars
four guys needs to be free to play yeah
yeah i i i agree
and i disagree i do feel like they um
fortnite had
competition for the most part i don't
think fault guys has competition
besides you know the overall install
base of all the consoles in the pc
and we have jd gamer with the five
dollar super chat slapped up
in the back somebody gets slapped
in the cookie jar it seems like these
movie studios are a lot better marketing
promotion and visual effect graphics i
think microsoft needs a movie studio
um i think that that he has a lot of
point there because
i think that's one of the reasons sony
is so good at you know how they present
stuff how they how they show a product
to the industry and to the
consumers is because you know they they
probably have a lot of cross
marketing going on and the person that's
marketing the gaming divisions also
marketing movies so
mm-hmm continues though
yeah get these next two attic please
i thought it was you so be it will be
the chat like yo he's batman in attic
house what's going on
very quiet in my white house right now
we got a ten dollar super chat from jd
gamer what do you guys think would have
happened if microsoft movie studios
would have been kept
and not closed after quantum break would
we have more graphically intense games
you guys we wouldn't have no game pass
the hell with them throw them in the
bushes
scrub nurse
yeah of course i've got got it i'm
hoping they stay with pattinson and run
multiple movies but please
keep director and cast for continuity
like marvel dc has the blueprint to
follow from marvel they need
to make this come up yes definitely they
got it they gotta pick with something
i was asking that you have something to
say i didn't
deal with a job
from jd gamer nice to see you here neo
hashtag
great content thank you jd but to answer
your question
quantum break oh
quantum break was hot garbage because
they wanted to wrap it around the tv
every time they talk about tv
tv with element with game it's certain
halo and not to mention on the pc
version it didn't even
you could close it there was no quick
button
yeah there was no quit button yeah
all right cool so um yeah you got your
joint off as far as the
the dc attic as far as what you felt
about the fandom
games yeah
when it comes to it like when it comes
to movies just like how i feel about
marvel
i'm not one of these people that like
you know microscope the
the comics you this the shoulder is
wrong it's not the same as this
comic man no no no like i don't care
you show you present to me a good movie
that has
you know beginning middle and end and it
makes sense and i'm okay with it like a
lot of people don't like superman
batman versus superman i liked it i
thought it was a good show maybe it's
because
you know it had a lot of emphasis behind
you know how everything was delivered in
terms of
you know the combat uh scenes like there
at the end with when they were fighting
dooms i think that's his name i don't
know
but you know so and i i really enjoyed
wonder woman
so you know wow
he said man it was fantastic wonder
woman was hot
i'm not you know i'm not so lucky to you
you don't make me a fraud with certain
she's definitely easy on the eyes so
so i thought that uh
dc phantom they were more prepared than
anybody else that came before and and
shout out to everybody else who had
these shows excuse me that was working
through this pandemic
that was helping them build their show
right
because it seemed like they learned a
lot from everybody else
yeah and like neil said it felt like i
was at comic con
yeah it had that feel all the hits
that was dropping and what are you
serious
it it made me feel
like i wasn't missing out and that they
were doing such a fan service
yeah excuse me they was doing such a fan
service that
every fan no matter what genre you was
at if you was at games you was at
movies you was at books you were
satiated with
all this information that came out i
love the fact that i got
finally the information that i wanted on
dr fate which is one of my favorite uh
dc characters and they also talked about
uh the flashback movie with the flash
they
uh went more into snyder cut which looks
great compared to that travesty of a
movie that they put out the first time
and i just feel that right now
with the brutality i've seen in batman
see
you guys didn't live through val kilmer
mm-hmm all right i
lived through bat nipples okay
elmer george clooney like oh yeah that
that stuff
it scarred me it started me and when i
see the level of brutality
in this batman in that trailer yeah when
he said who are you
and he proceeded to beat the snack out
of that dude
yes with without holding back yes
mr patterson i wait with baited breath
for this movie because i feel that they
picked the right person
yep and i just i i think
he makes that transition that addict
says yeah
yeah because he's able to play
bruce wayne but the psychological
thriller that i think that's
that they're playing out here because if
you looked at the joker movie that was a
psychological thriller
right and i believe that they're making
this batman the batman
in the same vein and they showed you
with the red logo
that it's going to be in your face
brutal
from the from the jump they took they
went away with the blue the soft touch
yeah they went with this red that shows
you is going to be very bloody very
visceral
but when he's going against the riddler
and you see the riddler put duct tape
around the guy's
head yeah this they're going
where the books go yeah and they're
using the source material now
and i feel that they got it right now so
yeah i i i walked away from that thing
like
it was so much stuff and i was just
champion sovereign the whole time
through
everything that popped up i was like
this man was dead on it
100 when they showed the shazam stuff
when they they showed the black adam
stuff
and i said it's about time that they get
some type of representation
in this manner and it was fantastic
that's what's up absolutely
did we get another super chat i thought
we had one from uh squirrely i saw one
squirrel with the two dollars but martha
let me jump in um for me like i said
i'll be i'll be the first man like
i'm a dc fraud i don't i don't know
what's good if you guys are happy that's
all i care about
you guys are good they did it up all
right
you know i said for me i'll be here for
these games though so that's where i was
at so for me
you know we got the what is it the super
squad social squad review we got let's
go with the first one right the first
one that was so unexpected guys
so unexpected guys we're getting a
quarter volts game
i could have never expected this never
no way never in a million years
so like i said
he's stupid he's ridiculous
definitely caught my eye like what i was
saying for me i like how they kind of
set it up like yo batman dead
so yeah like this is the doo doo and
then we i was at nightwing
bad girl and and the crew and her
red hood yeah robin so i thought that
was cool you know what i'm saying and
then i like i like that fight
of that whole setup when they got to the
mr freeze joint i thought that was fire
um i i didn't know it's a pre-alpha bill
i didn't know it's a little framing this
with certain things
let that rock it's pre-alpha build but
it looked good i'll be i go
from now i will say this and i have to
ask some of this because he's
missed a single player selfish
experience you know how are you feeling
about co-op
in your game sir you're gonna have to
play with us these are the games you go
in the corner
and you don't totally have to
let's be real here they said you can
play it but ai will take over
the other people do you really want to
play with ai
that's funny i ignore them anyway
so i'm i'm fine with it um i honestly i
just want to see w montreal get out from
under the shadow of rocksteady yeah yeah
i think uh arkham origins got a really
bad rap like
and for no reason really because it was
it was a good game it wasn't
great but then uh when you look at the
issues that people have with arkham
knight
um i i just thought the the the
magnifying glass
that was on awkward more origin was was
even less warranted you know
um so i just wanted them to do something
different and the fact that batman
batman isn't dead so let's go yeah
no absolutely i love the fact that
they're willing to go and say you know
what we're going to focus on these other
four characters
of the bat family and um i like the fact
that it's it seems like it's going more
in into sort of an rpg right where it's
you're going to have leveling up
you're going to have you have xp um you
like this
i like that girl as a service you like
this no but that's the thing
it's not as a service we'll talk about
suicide squad in a minute
that's that but i just think this is
more like what assassin's creed has
become like
it's it's kind of an rpg see like
destiny to me i'm just curious how you
feel about all this no
me this is the batman game for me i
still think it's it's in that realm
i think they just they've it's more of
an rpg right
so you're gonna have because if you look
at the trailer right batman in the
trailer says look i'm leaving you the
belfry as
the point of operations but the tech is
the tech is is
is is outdated yes right so it gives you
the
the indication that all of these
characters have like a skill tree that
they're gonna be improving upon
throughout the game
and that's fine by me uh in terms of
like you know seeing the numbers go down
above
above the enemies and stuff again that's
fine by me so as long as it's not
a service-based thing um and even as a
as a service-based thing my issue with
destiny is not the story content
there's numbers on their heads and the
enemy scale
according to your difficulty so if you
level up it's the freeze levels up
that's not
certainly scaling in my mind and my hope
is my hope is that it's taking the
nemesis system to the next level all
right my hope is that they've been
preventing nemesis here
and it's taking that to the next level
um so i don't think this
game in particular looks like game as a
service i think it's good the one thing
that has me a little
about it is is that if because it is a
cross-gen game
um you were probably going to see that
same thing that we saw in the other
arcane games was like okay let's find a
reason to empty out
our um gothic city and have no
npcs walk in the streets you know and it
seems like it's that again and i didn't
want to see that but as a crosstalk game
that might be a concession that we have
to deal with right um
but beyond that i think i think it's
it's it's good for them to be able to
sort of get out of the shadow of
rocksteady
show that they can do their own thing
and do their own thing well and then you
know
and sort of spotlight the bat family in
a way that we haven't seen before i mean
we saw some of that in arkham
arkham knight with some dlc
all about them okay so i'm happy about
that out of curiosity you
you think the nemesis engine's gonna be
in here have they confirmed that
no they have nothing to do with the
system
it would definitely be more appealing to
me but like seeing like
the trailer just like didn't give me
that vibe
once they said the level scaling like
cox said i was like all right
it'd be it would suck if it's just some
regular level scaling i think it's i
think it's gonna be some regular scale
oh no i mean it's my hope but again i i
don't i didn't see the game of the
service stuff i do
feel it though and we can i know i don't
want to segue because you guys haven't
talked about what you
you know king talk about yeah i'm just
going to finish my last point and i'll
give it back to neon king
which was just uh obviously the uh
suicide squad joint you know trailer
looked good i don't know what the game
is is it the shooter is it a four-player
co-op shooter is it
what is it but i thought it was fun i
don't think the company knows yeah
yeah but it's a ways out it's 20 22. you
know um
i thought it was funny obviously i i
like the concept i like the concept of
they got to go kill the justice league i
want to hear how they deal with their op
superman i thought that little skit was
funny
but let me give it back to you rocks in
a pocket
how would they beat superman now two hot
rocks in your pocket go punch
man what did you think about the two
games i'm sorry let's get it yeah i'm
sorry you're right
we got a couple super chats before we do
that we got shroom kingdom with the two
dollars super chat that mcdonald's
batman forever glass mug was fire though
hey hey i get that
but you know in the bushes with that
black ronin look at my
super chat we need phil to push billions
up to wb
so at 20 20 20 that that for some reason
i just have a feeling like
the search timed out the servers again
yeah there it
[Music]
part of me when it comes to certain
superheroes like
i feel like the games would be hard to
make and i do feel like
like superman i think that's a hard game
to make because if flying
for some reason every time i've seen
flying superhero games it seems like the
flying part's the hardest part to do
that makes it effective i think his
speed would be hard to mimic in a video
game
you know a great superman game you don't
even play superman at all you just play
car can't and you just sit at a desk
no we got jonathan wilson with the 5
super chat do any of you feel that they
are trying
the new batman movie with the that
they're trying to do batman
with the latest joker movie no um that
is definitely not
it looked like the thugs that batman
beat up had joker faces
um actually yeah they confirmed this um
initially it was thought that the movies
would tie in together
but if you look at the trailer um
there's there's lcd
there's lcd like computer monitors
there's cell phones
so they're definitely not in the same
time okay yeah
then we have erotis for the five dollar
super chat gotham knight will be in the
bushes if sony pulled that character
exclusive with a batman in it
oh no wow that'll be crazy
then we have the wise old gamer with the
five dollar super chat
thanks to margot robbie and gal gadot i
had to drop my tcl
and up my blue pill doses wow wow
wow
oh good then we
anthem was not to par but the flying was
on point
that is one of the very few games i've
seen flying done well done well yeah it
did fantastic
so let's get dealing well but then again
they didn't do anything with the flying
so i guess it was easy to make you do
well
in the bushes scroll down one more one
more y'all one more
grub sorry neil
it's looking a little suspicious with
the xbox tweets about wb games
and uh wonder woman 84 movie then all
the games on
sale decisions just watch it yeah they
wanted that
list i love it i love it let's see yeah
so let's get deal man these two games
now you know like yeah how are you
feeling
yeah so i'm not gonna lie um my initial
impressions of gotham night i saw the
trailer and i
i i thought the same thing i'm like oh
great here we go live service
yeah there you go news coming so i'm
like past
but then i you know i took some time i
rewatched the trailer yeah and i don't
know if you all checked out the 4k
version of it yeah it looks a lot better
so i don't know why folks really
complained that much um but i understand
you know still an alpha
um i like the idea of it i like how it
seems like it's still going to be a
single player narrative you just have
the option of playing with your friends
um it seems like this game is going to
be
more the um arkham style of combat thing
some more tradition and then suicide
squad
is going to be the experimental one it's
kind of weird though because i was
reading some things about it
apparently rocksteady at one point was
developing
like what wb montreal is and w montreal
was working on the suicide squad thing
but
i guess like the teams couldn't work
with one of them and so they swapped it
gotcha so um the the gotham knights one
i think
it can be cool you know provided
everything is in line and it works
the only thing that bothers me what and
and this is what's gonna bother me with
suicide squad is the way wb is gonna
handle
the post release content in dlc because
i didn't like how they did it with um
arkham knight and with arkham origins
even though i thought it was a decent
enough game
um the fact that they prioritized the
dlc over fixing the console versions
right i think that's what turned people
off but i mean i i think it'll be cool
for a playthrough again played with a
friend
suicide squad i don't know
i don't have an opinion on it because
like y'all said we don't even know what
it is
yeah could it be like a shooter i mean i
think this one is not going to be more
like the arkham games i think every
character's gonna play
like we've never seen before in an
arkham series um but they were talking
like
yeah you know you'll have this campaign
and it'll be all for them they'll be ai
so it's kind of gonna be like left or
dead in a sense you know just drop
in drop out y'all do that so it it could
be fun uh we we have two years to go so
what materializes from now to then we'll
we'll just have to see but
um i i if i had to take a guess i think
that one's gonna be more of the service
route where they'll go and do those sort
of things which
we'll just have to see two years long
time long two years long time
it'll be seven years at that point oh
yeah absolutely bro
we're talking about arkham knights right
yeah well
that was not what you're talking about
yeah yeah
yeah that game's gonna be all garbage
nothing nothing about that trailer
screamed like i need to play this like
you know that's your thing go play it
like no i like what suicide squad like i
like the concept behind what's going on
there
but the fact that both of these games
will be games as a service like
can we please stop with these games as a
service like
the first one is not a game as a service
no no it definitely looked scream games
to the surface
it is what it is man it is what it is
like i am trying to play none of that
stuff so none of them interested you is
basically your point suicide squad
see like the concept of you know
fighting superman seemed interesting
i don't know man nothing like the movies
i like the movies but i like the wonder
woman trailer more i like all
my guys we understand we understand why
we understand why sir
continue oh my god shout out to you
we have king one supreme with the five
dollar super chat saints row four is how
superman game can play
same with that game undefeated yeah
mm-hmm
okay all right so um when i saw the
trailer 4k trailer pop up boom i'm like
oh god right so i made sure i turned the
lights off right wow
and i had my little drink in my hand and
i'm sitting there shaking well you got
to turn the lights off
cinematic experiences with 77-inch
televisions
anyway
all right so anyway i turned the lights
off like i said
and i hit i hit the play button with the
lights up correct
if you're getting this message i'm dead
i'm dead
like i'm like yo they're doing it they
actually
they're doing it they're doing it and
i said well we're going to probably just
get cgi we're not going to get any game
play you're mr gameplay you hate
i said first of all first thing that
popped in my head is
oh i'm definitely gonna go buy this
batgirl statue
that's one um i'm definitely i want to
know which robin this is is this damien
or who who who's just robbing him
okay okay
i'm not up to date on like the whole
superman like
anything that like and batman i thought
nightwing was robin
like he was yeah
yeah he was the first robbie he's the
first yeah he uh just threw it into his
whole
different pretty much the one that took
over batman's play after no
he didn't he
anyway this is not a dc tutorial um
it's showing that you have to turn your
lights off to julia i'm sorry i'm sorry
you can't turn the lights off to watch
ips sir all right
continue let me get my part so i can
just move on
so anyway so when i'm seeing it and then
i'm seeing the
cinematic aspects to it and that's the
drop-in
instant uh co-op i said oh
this is what i'm talking about now no
longer do i have to sit there like if my
son want to play he could just jump in
and play right there or somebody's
online and they see me playing they want
to jump in
they can play and i saw different
aspects of every character
like how bad girl plays like batman
she's the more traditional when it comes
to batman
uh you know um tim tim drake
he plays more like a techie type of guy
because he's able to teleport to short
distances
red hood is going to have the gun so
he's going to probably be your range
character
and you know i don't know how nightwing
works he probably is more of the melee
character like fast combat
stronger so i saw they still kept the
cinematic aspects to it
and it blew me away the level 11
anticipation for the game is super high
i'm a fan of what they do i'm a fan of
the giant i'm a fan of batman games in
general
so i'm definitely so dope now
uh-oh the suicide squad stuff
when i thought nothing but cgi i kind of
figured
and i said who are they using mm-hmm
and they're gonna let me know the world
that they're in
mm-hmm right and then when i saw this
using shark okay and i saw
how harley quinn looked i said okay
they're using the
else world type of feel what's old it
that it was going to be not canon with
superman suit
look at his suit it's not the cannon
suit
it's like from injustice type of suit
yeah and i said
maybe this is the prequel to injustice
for right before superman goes off the
deep end
and i said if they play that aspect of
it
they got a winner i don't know what the
game is going to be and like
i said maybe it's like different
characters do different things
and you see deadshot uh the way he's
using his guns and stuff without looking
and shooting
that's a good aspect and boomerang so
i'm going to have fun
with that game when it comes out
whatever it might be i'm definitely
going to try it
right but i was i was happy to know that
it's uh
they're going to take risks with it
because they're going to actually
probably kill
superman and kill wonder woman when it's
not
canon they kill them right
yeah what do you guys see man is it
interesting i thought it was like
rumored in the same rumor it said that
like a lot of the bigger name
people in the in the dc like they they
don't die like superman just grabs them
and takes them away
you mean an injustice they don't really
kill anybody yeah i mean
um what i what i do know is that rock
study said that this is definitely
continuing the arkham verse
so the events that happen at the end of
arkham knight you'll see
the impact of that in what happens with
these characters
uh uh different to what wv montreal said
that
even though it's the circumstances seem
similar to the end of arkham knight
it is a different timeline so it has
nothing to do with that
so yeah so i i don't know i don't know
this is a game that to me look very much
like a games as a service thing the fact
that they're gonna take seven years to
make it makes me think like there's some
server stuff that they need to work on
right so um and like king said when you
look at the lineup
um the only one that kind of sticks out
like a sort of thumb is king shark right
right and it's just because the other
ones have been
parts of a variety of different suicide
squad teams
right so when you look at king shark and
just his build or whatever you see him
as a tank character right so okay
so these characters are going to sort of
be placed in classes
and and the gameplay is going to be kind
of
revolve around that then it makes sense
that you would have this sort of tank
character along with this melee
character
but one thing they they specified that
they really talked about was the gun
combat the gun combat was going to be
prevalent
in this game overall which was a little
strange to me i was like so they're all
going to have
sort of long-range weapons and making a
shooter like should i say
shooter mechanics yeah so um not much to
talk about there
interesting um again a lot of people i
i've seen people online saying oh this
already looks better than
than the wb game and i'm like you didn't
see anything what are you talking about
like
xbox buy these guys
some people are really out there hating
just for the sake of hating
to be honest with you though i know this
could be an unpopular opinion but uh
i i i think that cgi is a suicide squad
look better than that marvel game coming
up this is oh yeah
wow that marvel game looks like that
kind of game i launched just to take a
picture of the title screen just to talk
[ __ ] about it
oh deal you down with the sled
i don't know any of y'all who think like
waiting to download a 30 gig
by beta is fun
a similar path that anthem
he's like yo i like him myself yeah
that's that dc i see what
50-inch pythons
tv by dawn yeah we have echelon the dark
with the five dollar super chat
if xbox buys black myth wu kong and
bright memory
they'll have two next level coders and
two chinese
you don't just like that you haven't
stopped talking about this
like you wasn't all four guys sir oh man
let's
be real anyway like i always say shout
out to my uh
my wukong guards in the realm right now
you know what i'm saying we were waiting
for our moment patiently but um yeah man
got like three people in the chat
interesting
it's just getting a lot of traction
listen man this was definitely one of
the biggest surprises this week man and
uh yeah definitely case black myth woo
kong new dark souls should we say souls
like song
no oh i would i wouldn't say that oh
my god
yeah that's dope salute welcome to the
run welcome to the realm so yeah man
again based on that old
like i said the mythology the chinese
journey to the west and um yeah
developed by
i called them affectionately what is it
the game science
almost reminds me king remember this
gotcha man
it's like the game science ninja team
that's what it sounds like dude
so salute to them man again this thing i
hate a whole site salute to the again in
the realm
but um yeah man so again this thing came
out you know small relatively small team
i think they originally would um
tencent then they had some other games
that they developed prior
and this thing took over the internet i
mean
the amount for like three hours i'm
joking
let's give another shout out to my man
super g
hey that's the homie
yeah glad that you're doing great
brother
and i see you trying to get that xbox
series x now
well considering you guys are in the
realm you know you might want to stay to
the end of the show
oh yeah yeah yeah man so look this thing
definitely you know
broke the internet i believe the the
view count
there's a chinese affiliate i think it's
called bilby or something like that i
forgot the name of it
but yeah i'm watching it right now it's
got over 3 million 3 million views and
on youtube it's shattered so i just
wanted to bring this to the realm
you know what are our thought process on
it what do we feel about it and then um
something i actually put a tweet out and
uh i have put like i said like you know
phil davids paging phil dominance that's
it
i got actually it got more positive than
hey it kind of went viral this tree i
was just being silly
you know saying something that uh
microsoft should look into because i
believe it is coming to
next generation platforms as well as
cloud streaming platforms as well
currently on unreal engine 4
that this was done and so let's get
let's get neal right in first did you
see
the uh the trailer and what are your
thoughts about it
you know in general hold on apologies
okay go ahead go ahead
we got pixel big g with the two dollar
super chat woo kong was the best game
showing for e3 225
facts and then we have to welcome
another member to the realm michael
askew welcome to the world
what's up i know
all new members please stick around to
the end of the show to make sure that
you watch the video
so you can understand how you can win
that xbox series x let's go next
facts a little we got some cool members
in the realm that's what's up so yeah
back to you lord neil
blackmith wukong what would you feel
what [ __ ] what's your vibes on it man
dude i'm digging it i'm digging i like i
love all the stories about journey to
the west
and things like that and it's it's a
shame that it hasn't been like fully
realized now
in a full big budget game and the fact
that they're doing this it looks great
um it'll be interesting to see
because they set a date for it at all no
this is still involved
okay so depending on like if they
transition this to unreal engine 5 or
not
it'll be interesting to see how that um
plays out but yeah the the chinese
market is booming
it's growing and you know like just this
game coming out
and just taking the internet by storm
like regardless of whether or not it's
three hours or not
it just reaffirms why a first impression
is just
so dang important preach and you need
you need to nail that even if it's for a
game that's not coming out for two years
you just you got to get people on board
because there's already people saying
like oh great yes this is a game that i
want to play in a few years
i love it so i'm excited to see um what
comes from this and
potentially what will happen in the
future as far as
other studios because like it's been
mainly this generation they've been
booming
yes but if you have like a game that
just puts them on the map yo sony
microsoft they're gonna start looking
into things
bruh facts that's what i'm talking about
man chinese developers on the rise right
now
let's get attic the perpetual hater uh
what is your feeling sir
of uh black myth i i think when it comes
down to it
i just got to see more in terms of like
because i saw the boss fight you already
fought the wearable thing
and um i like the way it looked i just
got to see you know how variety of
different kind of boss fights mechanics
are in
like for the most part you know i saw
that clone move he did
yeah that that was cool
look how excited this man dude why can't
i be excited
damn i'm just joking
but um so when it comes down to it i got
to see more
stuff like that more uniqueness that i i
just i'm not trying
to say that about
but this is what you did i just want to
be clear
[Laughter]
i got to see more on it but you know it
it looks like a decent game i just got
to see more on terms of
how the boss mechanics are i don't doubt
no fair enough fair enough perpetual
hater number two lord king um
right quick um let's get the hate right
out the way let's go
um as far as hate i'm just calling you a
fraud because you don't know nothing
about the monkey game
oh that's right because if i don't know
the exact source material i can't like
it i mean
you know
when i saw it and it was like because
somebody tagged me and i'm like what
this
is it was probably called needle
attacking
page uh essential yeah absolutely
yeah he hit me up and he when he tagged
me tagged me phil and somebody
excuse me phil dominus maximus
so um when when he tagged me i'm like
what's this so i clicked it and then i
said what is this little bug
and the little bug is flying and i'm
like yo this bug look all clean man this
look clean
and then i noticed that it was current
gem all right so a lot of people looked
at it was like oh this next gen gameplay
that was current gen gameplay that was
not next-gen gameplay when you saw the
fur on the boss
it was current gen but what i like in
place that the fact that they was using
unreal engine
and what is explained to us by tim
sweeney himself uh
the bully he is affectionately called
the bully he says that you know
uh going from unreal engine 4 is a whole
lot easier than from three to four from
four to five
so uh adding all that extra bells and
whistles uh polishing it up all the way
through because the game looks like
concept design and execution
is there they're looking for polish
and usually polish and bug testing takes
a year
or 18 months you know during that period
of time
and we don't know given this pandemic
exactly what but being that it's a
individual that was working on it or
smaller team
they're able to work a lot more
efficiently than
larger teams because you know they get
tested they're in the same space
and they can work together and get a lot
more things achieved
now when i saw the transitions i saw the
parrying
i saw uh when he beat a foe
he absorbed absolutely they took the
fire staff
right and that fire came into play
when he was fighting the furbies
yes i love the level of
attention to detail when
he was going to finish the the
wolf character and
his future self god mode
showed up and and it automatically threw
me for luke i'm like how are they
existing in the same plane so what's
what's going automatically i said what's
going on so when when
when he when he did his uh jitsu and he
had multi-clones that was awesome to me
i thought it was fight i was like yo
naruto feels all over my body
i'm like this is definitely what they
need
now everybody calling out microsoft
should buy them yeah listen in the ideal
world
you want your console of choice to get
them right
good what i want is that it definitely
makes it over to a console
i don't care which console gets it to be
honest with you i just want it to get
published i want them to get the backing
that they need
because he put his best foot forward
that is
probably the best looking thing i've
seen
this year yeah out of only
all that's what i was about to say
that's what got me so hyped i know added
getting on me but
i got to cut you because it's like let's
be real there's no disrespect
to playstation 5 or series x right right
we know these things are going to be
beasts
but i felt coming in you know i haven't
got that
feeling like yo the next gen is here and
this
current gym game you could have lied to
me and said that this was next-gen
and i would have been like yo the next
gen gonna be
crazy when he was fighting 500 dudes and
you could only do that with the terror
flops possible with the next gen console
son
like i would have been capping yo uac
the ssd
the velocity of architecture when he
fought all those gods it's only
possible son like i wouldn't tapping
this man
no i swear to god that's all the stuff
that i heard everything that he said
right there
has been all my timeline
they could have lied to me and i would
have been capping
like yo i see it i see the nvme right
there
just just out of curiosity the nvme
you make this game look next-gen bro
but yeah
and that boy you saw that boy saw where
he flying on the cloud
when he fought in the cloud and that's
that to me when they when he was
fighting like the
the hundred dudes on the clouds yes he
was in god mode
i was like did you see that stage where
i don't know what stage it was it looked
like it was
four like almost celestials or god like
creatures that was ready to get it in
with him
and i'm like the scale of this game in
the very low i'm like yo what
what's going on like somebody gotta get
him the bag bro like all right
all right so let me ask the chat
something yeah i'm curious how many
people in the chat all right
all the people in the chat i was gonna
do this like a members uh but we're just
gonna do it just one and two
put a one if you think this game looked
next-gen and put it too if you do not
think this game looked next year yeah
that's a good question that's a good
question
but i'm sorry i could tell you okay i
was just gonna get too high no no no no
that was it that's the price
listen i can't say more uh uh
things about the game that you're going
to say everybody saw the same thing
we feel the same way about the game we
want to see more we want to know where
it's going to be
how can we uh attain playing this game
they they're out there the only thing
that showed me that it was current gen
was when i saw the fur mechanics on
a couple of the characters and i saw
that and i was like oh but everything
else
looked absolutely ridiculous
all these ones they clearly have a
switch and they got cataracts
we got mods with the ten dollars
salute continue uh that's it all right
solve it let's get your thoughts that i
get mine
1.5s and i'm making them twos by the way
you're rounding up
okay there we go you have jd game with
two dollar super chat microsoft shut
sony up
and give them these guys and get back
guys phil get on the phone stop playing
good yeah um i've always been a big fan
of the monkey king lore uh sung
kong the journey to the west like i i
read the novelization like
so um to see it brought to life in this
way
is it's kind of bonkers because when you
have a chinese team working on it right
what you can
expect is that even the the minutia of
the lore
is going to make itself its way into the
game in a way that's
that that they understand more than
anyone else um so to see those things
like the
the the god mode transformation and the
the the battles up in the clouds and
stuff this is
the fantasy that i want to see from a
wukong story from a wukong game
absolutely go bonkers so when i saw that
i was like wow they're really doing it
um so when you mentioned when you
mentioned like a kind of the souls like
thing you know what it felt like to me
because i know i know king didn't like
necessarily the direction where god of
war went yeah it felt like i got a war
it felt like oh god of war right yeah it
felt like god of war
three amped up and
what king wanted it to be this
generation yeah
because of because there's parts where
you see him scaling this big giant as
well right
yes oh i forgot that yeah yeah yeah i
had all of those elements in it in a way
and what what it also did was right if
you have any sort of
not any beef with old god of war is that
after a while the combat didn't feel
super rewarding like you would see these
massive like fights or whatever
but the combat didn't feel rewarding in
the way like
that your enemies were really able to
hurt you like you were destroying them
right
so what i see in this is that the
enemies are very capable
right in a way and i'm you know people
gonna be mad at me but
that's why i've fallen off a little bit
on goes to sushi month
because tsushima like i'm playing the
game on hard um
and i still feel like it's a parry fest
like yeah it's a very fast attack parry
attack parry attack
it doesn't feel except when you're doing
like the the one-on-ones
where it feels like there's more of a
back and forth it gets sort of samey
with these it seems like every character
right
boss characters characters you meet
along the way they're they're gonna be
somewhat of a challenge right but not
necessarily the same way the dark souls
game is
yeah um i from what i saw i i was
impressed
i want to see more of that i want to see
these guys get the bag
and bring it over and get the shine they
deserve yeah
um so i hope it happens yeah let's get
to the chat then i'll say my final
comment and i want it um
jd gamer oh hold on we jumped a little
bit two dollar super chat microsoft oh
we did that one already
i have michael skew with the five dollar
skill
the game mark my knees will not come out
encouraging
this is pretty alpha and the dev team is
still trying uh to up their staff to 30
people
fire so barry make her and jen and we
have jd gaming with the 5
super chat one of my favorite games was
uh ninja theories enslaved odyssey to
the west yes
and slave was fantastic um i need this
game remade and the sequel who's with me
okay not fair enough fair enough look
i'll get my final bars off obviously i
know i'm super hyped for this thing
um i just want to salute the chinese
statement
i don't know why this man is mad at my
excitement but anyway
salute to the chinese dabs want to come
up because again you know
you're seeing what's coming out of there
and you know no disrespect they've
always been kind of
kind of entrenched in the mobile space
and i think that what's dope about this
especially this is why i got excited
about bright memory infinite this is the
same kind of a situation
i believe that was like one person but
this is another smaller team it looks
like they
finally have the tools to now jump into
the triple a space
and that excites me to see this level
of polish and detail and yo it was so
crazy because
the team they were surprised by all the
positive feedback they were getting
right
and what happened is they got one of the
dev the lead therefore that deal was
like
hey we apologize you know the the water
wasn't physics wasn't right the music
and i'm like bro this was the greatest
thing this year like you good like
the world lo and he's like we're
probably gonna go back in hiding and
make it right
and i'm like no y'all y'all lit like
don't worry like you good you don't say
so it was real it was real cool to see
so again
seeing that these guys finally getting
those um those levels of tools
as far as the technology and i believe
um
a lot of the traditional western the
powerhouses like ubisoft
epic games they're starting to train
these guys like these these highly
skilled uh developers
in operations in china so they're on the
come up man so it's good to see
and like i said brighter memory info
there's another game i believe it was a
soul aside lost holiday or something
like that
yeah yeah man they were to come up so
keep an eye on that shout out to the
game
science ninja team got your mind i'm
calling them put it out
and uh yo i can't wait to see this thing
but that's all i got on it anything we
got left fellas we roll up
man let's give him the bag let's keep
tensing away from them
phil do what you got to do even if it's
a term exclusive
these are the games is these are the
games
that get people excited like you want
that level when you see in that level of
engagement
as far as youtube and all this other
stuff give them the bag
let them work and people trust me you
get these type of people who will come
and flock to the system now
but that's what i got yeah stitch and
let's get it
we got stitch with the five dollar super
chat disclaimer should have been added
uh
black myth not captioned on the tcl have
a great day
so let's get the poll over to ielts
people with his latest reveals at dc
fandom of suicide squad and gotham
knights which has you
most excited for release the choices are
a
sewer skate squad team up shooters to
kill
the good guys b got them nice
knights post batman for the win
or c i don't care stop these games as a
service superhero games
killing my single player experiences
that is the question those other choices
please rock that when it goes up on the
ilp
twitter lord neo game spark rock it out
with us the whole marathon kept him
hostage
salute to him for his patience and his
stamina
but uh absolute pleasure to have you in
the room man where can i find people
find you and what do you have going on
sir
of course of course so y'all can find me
uh my name is pretty much the same
across everything it's just at
neogamespark youtube.com
neogamespark uh that's where i like to
uh frolic and congregate
as far as um videos to expect this week
yeah i got a couple of uh
topics that i wanted to cover of course
every monday i do the uh
ask neo weekly q a yes sir and uh yeah
this is i i don't know why i'm
mentioning this but i gotta say
in terms of merch y'all got a really
good store oh wow
yeah like the uh the gyms are gonna be
opening up here in new york soon and
these tank tops looking nice you see me
out here
i'm modeling them trying to sell them
yeah yeah it's good
it's good i got the the different
colorways so i'm just like yo i i got to
support the homies because
i don't i don't say this i don't say
it's often because you know me i just
try to be real but
this has definitely been like the best
podcast
experience that i've ever been on like
from beginning to end
like it's just non-stop laughs jokes
inside jokes everything
that tcl thing my god
yo bro you don't have no idea how much
that we used to hear that from everybody
we're so humble
and just to have you around you taking
the time out of your day you know what
i'm saying to to come out and hang with
us
watch us be silly i told you you're
gonna have some fun
he's not ready for what he's about to
get into but to hear you guys to hear
our peers say that it means a lot and
again
brother keep doing what you're doing so
proud of you like just to see your
journey how long you've been doing it
and then the objectivity and obviously
the magic moments these milestones that
you're hitting
uh super proud again set no setting the
lane for for ign for us and you know
things that we can aspire to so keep up
the fantastic you know we got to bring
it back you know that got to happen at
some point in the future
yeah yeah y'all y'all know just hit me
up on here make sure you're back for our
tlc gonna happen again
this is dlc
when i upgrade my tv he never brings up
tlc ever again
oh shout out to one bad mother with the
super chat facts [ __ ] little dude's
going to
compete with triple a production values
next gen what does that mean for gay
passing me and phil need to drop the bag
off and get it i mean that
gamepad's gonna have all those games in
there too that's what i mean
care about nothing else other than that
game because his medium and game pass
off
i'm not sure if it ain't it's not
getting played
right now i went into the store
yesterday right i went into the store
yesterday and i'm checking let's on game
pass
um and certain things come up on
gameplus already medium does not come on
come up with the game
they said everything will be in game
pass medium was was oh yeah
i can't remember i don't know anyway no
it was it was a third party showcase and
they showed it again and they showed it
again
okay well you know what it better show
up in game pass that's all
chat says it's in gamepad rank g4 files
of a chat tcl sounds like a sports
injury yo yo stupid
where can you find you what you got
going on sir you can
find me hiding from the tco police
you can also find me on twitter lord
addicts iop you can find me at uh
youtube at gaming addict i'm gonna
probably be uh posting a video about
playstation now in game pass uh
i think it's time that i compare those
two because i got i got i found my play
station
it went missing for like two weeks but
that's besides the fact so uh
you know definitely want to appreciate
neil for coming on i want to thank all
the people in the
in the chat for coming through you know
definitely was up there we already have
174 likes trying to get that to 200 by
the end of the podcast
oh my god you're done son
look at you let's see we have a whole
week you play in that game
continue but uh you know definitely want
to appreciate everyone coming by
you know you guys come through every
week we try to give as good as a show as
we possibly can and uh you know you guys
seem to enjoy it so we're going to keep
doing what we do we'll see you next week
no doubt yo they funny with the jokes
they suffering from pcos
right so what i'll even do
is when i get the when i get the
overalls i i do a sneak peek i'll
post a twitter of what lord addict uh
the uh the trucker attic looks like that
that way you know what you don't
kind of you get a preview
uh you know where i'm going i'm going to
work so that's what i'm going to do
bro i i got to start getting ready for
work yeah you guys are
working the struggle is real
um a big shout out to neil man my man
i so proud of your journey so happy for
the success you're having
shout out to ny obviously oh new york in
the building let's go
listen new york content creators all too
often
in in this community you will find
people that find
a lot of success by being often times
nega
it's not everybody but oftentimes
negative uh polarizing
same thing just to sort of polarize one
base or another facts it is refreshing
and well deserved that someone who can
be objective about this and just talk
about things
the way that they are that's it um
finding success man so so happy for you
thank you for coming on the show today
really really appreciate your time
you already know and of course the super
chats are rolling this city smith
follows with every tcl sold and angel
loses his swing
desist i would not be surprised no we're
getting a season decision
once they get ahold of this podcast it's
over for us
tv and try to change them yeah they're
gonna send you a they're gonna say king
of tv to review
you better
crazy they're like addict already got a
tlc
let's let's let's sit on the kill okay
what are we going to do
what is this tlc that you got dc alice
sir you got the bootleg version of the
bootleg
yeah we need we need going into that
time
anyway lord king man where could i find
your fights what you got going on
first first first i would like to say oh
man brother uh when you popped up on my
timeline
i couldn't tell uh too many people but i
i couldn't tell enough people about you
right and i'm like
because usually i get the toxic
playstation fans
and it's just it's just a negative thing
when it when it comes to it so going
into the video i'm like oh what this guy
got to
and then say watching i'm like oh
subscribe
oh subscribe and it wasn't it wasn't
subscribe because you were seeing stuff
that were in line with my opinions of
the gaming console that i choose it was
because you just been real
yeah it was just factual and it wasn't
it was no cap it wasn't
it was just real then i watched other
videos and i said this
guy is genuine facts you are new york
bred
and born real yeah and you know
i swear i salute you and it is fantastic
to see you doing exactly what you're
doing especially
as a content creator of color thank you
so
much sir for conducting yourself in the
most professional manner
beautiful that's a big point yeah man
thank you so you guys can catch me
on twitter at king david otw
same thing with xbox live king david otw
on playstation playstation xbox 360
lover 01
i am not trolling you can catch me there
i got some magic cases that came in so
um this stuff is gonna start coming down
they're gonna start seeing the display
cases that i am putting up i did the
back room that's done
the front room is done so uh the
majority of the statues is going in the
back so i got enough space to fill up
a hundred more statues out that way and
at least 70 to 80 statues here
so uh i'm gonna start putting the magic
cases together i got the statue that
came in that's why you didn't get
anything this week
uh because everything has to be put
together so i'm trying to debate if i'm
going to do
one statue uh video and
a magic case video so you can see how to
properly uh
keep yo i'm trying to get [ __ ] to get
him out of case
cause he got that surfer on preo um but
yo
listen see you guys next week thank you
guys for rocking out watch the video at
the end
if you don't know about the giveaway
that we do have with lords of gaming.net
and iron lords podcast
uh with association with cac daddy fat
stacks
xbox series x will get to your hands and
you could be a lucky winner
so please stay tuned and just watch the
video at the end yeah man so you already
know
how to get over here again it was lit
super late again we shot some fun stuff
playing in the realm some things cooking
up
please stay tuned next week should also
be a fun show yo everybody enjoy
your sunday thanks for rocking out all
the way to the end we're gonna leave you
with this promo like king said and we
out of here
peace hi i'm lord king david of iron
lords podcast
and we're bringing to you an exciting
new giveaway
this giveaway is like none other we'll
be giving away
a xbox series x that's right
you heard me right the brand new console
launching from microsoft this year
well this is how you're able
to be part of that giveaway there's
two ways to get your name
thrown in the hat for the raffle
one become a member of the realm
that's hit that join button hit that joy
button you hit that join button down at
the bottom
and you can become a member and also
another way is by becoming a patreon
member
so you can be part of the realm as well
now this is brought to you by cat daddy
fat stacks
a member and lord of the realm
a very generous person that's in
our community and this community
is beautiful so remember
you can have one entry by hitting that
join button
and becoming a member of the realm and
also you can have another entry
by being a patreon now you said king
what if i'm a member of both well your
name gets thrown in the hat
two times so please
like follow and subscribe
join or become a patreon member
or become both and your name
is in the hat to get that
xbox series x
as to who did that for you sweepstakes
this is wonderful this is something that
i'm sure that you will enjoy
oh man